[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on
what's up people the Lords what it do
put the crests up
there it's Sunday it's a lordly day very
very spiritual orally day-to-day put the
crest up I see y'all in there already
Christopher Hart Thanksgiving cooking
what's up
akw my man what's going on throw it up
pop not David all right let me know my
levels is good
Sunday Sunday and all that
it's all good see what's going on hi
what's going on no doubt hustle what's
up brother man I hope you're doing all
right hope you're doing all right
checking in on you and everything else
we got up in the Cami Cami 28 what's up
and we got uh Spider what's going on
spider game Plateau what's going on
Coggin fellow low I see all right I like
that I like [ __ ] and fellow Lords that's
how it was before y'all was doing it
the Dell Kevin coats what's up what's up
what's up you already know dead proof
all right oh Hector the Macho Man with
the Super Chat for dollars all hail the
Lords on this beautiful Sunday I'm very
concerned that God I'll be getting the
year voters have not been sent a swag a
Sony care package for exclusive folks
y'all messy
yeah you looking for your bags
what's up
no doubt Nom Omar with the crash no
doubt far far Q what's up what's good
though Here Comes looking around for the
show yeah the music is going on game and
now mix what's going on brother good to
see you chase more say what's up Sunday
with the Lords we back another one
you're hot right kicking them dudes yeah
I know y'all better stop
so we go get uh my man saw bump in the
head King up and spoke to him have a
nice show some good topics some funny
topics a couple times I can't wait to
talk about but uh go to the people real
quick
oh I know what y'all talking about I
know what you talking about that's um
shout out to game on daily shout out to
ACG I know exactly which I'm staying out
of that
salute to my people though salute to
them they did their thing silver lab guy
what's going on oh hustle said what up
addict
you got the the little man's ready
I'm staying all out of that right there
buddy I know what you doing
yeah everybody old pal we ain't doing
that but salute to the salute to the
sauce I know how to Sauce it and ACG
together that sounded like a great show
I didn't get a chance to listen to it
try to do a little bit better about
listening to the podcast but it's been
I've been so busy
we will talk to y'all in a minute we'll
get solved with the crew up in here okay
hustle said turn attic up a little
please
I wasn't talking really okay okay thank
you hustle always making sure we sound
good y'all know they bad they big bad
Stitch is good so today we're going to
talk about certainly and what what's
other games
yo y'all best y'all don't know what's
gonna happen why you feel that way
Stitch you don't know what's going to
happen you know what Stitch I approved I
meant Oh see and then you wonder why you
get labeled
it's just ironic that's it okay you know
exactly
you'll be right lock stepping key with
King you just not his voice
[Music]
[Music]
all of them you
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
for your original y'all too Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
arson up in the apartment they call it
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them rain you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my city but I'm still
by Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
who
let's do that again
hear you hear me man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go hit it up find
yourself a spot get comfortable grab a
snack do all that good stuff that we
need to do in um you know about to get
started I am well it's not important who
I am uh what's important is that you are
pulling up to the iron Lords podcast
right now as we speaking uh I guess I'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just for
the original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they want to compare me
to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original you're also
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and snapping and
making it flammable this is that this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call it
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rains you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless back
when you was messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but coming to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headless be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original you're also
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and sampling making
it flammable this is that this is the
Yoga Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up
in the apartment they call a department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them Reigns you just
a Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back when
you was messaging people don't aim check
my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep I'm Freddy Krueger that's
whoo
let's do that again
[Music]
um
[Music]
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to a knee vendor I gotta be Neato
I know it's my destiny work to carnido
who cares if you fly if you stealing
mosquito you swear he ain't nothing but
really be Stevo you like to collect
stuff and that's cool but I got bad news
even if he really was that joke King
David still be the king of the statue
sister juvenile I've been cursed with a
curse to be Musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in The Crucible wasn't it
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful
we'll let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a Sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle on the Lord's day
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord day radio
[Music]
not yet I mean you're good though but
that we good bike check do it yeah there
you go I see I heard somebody sniffle
the sniffle came through hold on make
sure everything's good yeah see
everything good all right here you hear
you and we are live welcome to the iron
Lords podcast LLC and also live on the
Lords of gaming.net episode number 281.
that's another Glory Sunday we're back
at the round table on the Lord's date
and today who's that troubleshoot oh man
what's up brother I was like who that
look who troubleshoot game man
today we've got Phil Spencer's Verge
into interview
exotic Creator scandal
Xbox series S price drop epic versus
Google
and the game awards Crown your lord
nominees it sounds a little bit Regal
man with the Versace
and I want the chat to look at those
topics and try to and try to figure out
who's Kings yes
I bet you they can't guess it let's
figure out who's kicks topic is so let's
introduce the Four Horsemen of gaming
the original gaming Knights of the realm
here at the round table my co-host with
the cold most my brother from another
mother the difficult game conquer a lord
of his own world and the how of the
young wolf my man Lloyd addict of the
attic show and Pokemon what's up
all right so we we gotta talk about this
game for a second what happened
that look I I feel like they have
improved a lot when it comes to the
Pokemon franchise but they ruined just
as much like how it used to be a Pokemon
is like there would actually be a story
like you would go to these new regions
there would be a story but they have
decided that we don't care about story
anymore you know what we're gonna do
we're gonna we're gonna do what what the
um what they doing what breath of the
wild did we're gonna make everything
open world and now when stuff like what
actually happened and you would actually
go to these like regions and stuff it
used to be there there was like
scripting and stuff that would go on
there all right you're in this area now
you gotta deal with you know whatever
Team Rocket's variation was right
they're like we're just gonna put
something called team star and they
they're just gonna have these bases
around the map and that's that's all
you're gonna do it's just like I I feel
like they try to do they try to catch
that lightning the bottle with Pokemon
when it comes to the open War World
aspect of breath of the wild and it's
the same thing that I felt with breath
of the wild it's a fun game but it
doesn't feel like a Pokemon game like
there's not a whole lot of narrative
I've literally beat one one gym after
another and the only thing that happened
is like yo quote unquote rival just pops
like hey let's battle you can go to any
any gym you want right from the jump
from this jump but the thing is is the
level the question is is that boy still
10 years old
I don't know how old the uh
you said just yesterday
he actually for the first time ever I
think in the anime or whatever he became
the world champion
he's done it twice it's been 25 years
and this dude still being attacked
I'm only saying this because attic is
looking for them to do you know follow
these tradition rules and they still
can't get this dude age right
he wouldn't run her up and then the year
after that he won it and then he wanted
to get in this year like he literally
went like 15 years never winning yeah he
was always the worst Pokemon no no he
see every time he went into the uh into
the championship he got like a better
placement at eighth place fourth place
like but he never won so that that's so
that's his story king that's that he's
rising up
check it out the real twist about it is
is they're all vampires and they don't
age
it extends I gotta ask Atticus question
though because just yesterday y'all this
man was on the phone with me raving
raving up your Pokeball they did that yo
or Auto battles just the newest it's the
hottest it's the best one
you know what it is
so he can tell you something and then he
plays 10 hours of it
that's what it was see the honey
honeymoon phase lasts a lot along with
other people
unless like a whole two hours
I do think they put a lot of features
that people really enjoyed here like
um you know especially competitive
Pokemon people like having special moves
for certain Pokemon and it's been
annoying to get some of them so
sometimes but now they have like a TM uh
it's like pretty much the item where you
get the the most you can make that now
but it's just like I I just get I get
annoyed when they change foundations to
try to broaden the the audience open
world thing is is at this point now I
might get it it's a play that
all right I like that you said open
world okay they talking about like
now it's just
it sounds l-ringish it's not elderly it
kind of is like if you put that kind of
mindset it's just I think people get
this like really bad Vibe of like linear
experiences because Pokemon was was that
you you could only go so far to you do
the story things that is in that area
then they open it up to the next area
not every game has to be an open world
yo lotia said tell them about the
performance he won't know about the
performance oh man
no it's it's on fire on the ground it's
already fresh
and pieces on the ground better in dark
mode
you know what's funny because
um
that with let's go Pikachu and Eevee
they actually put the Pokemon on the
field like so you could see before you
actually go into a battle now okay well
the problem with this is I haven't
really played it like heavy heavy in a
few years so there's all these little
Pokemon now like little Pokemon like
this big on the screen so when you're
walking on the field you're accidentally
running into mad battles because they're
popping up at the last minute the pop-up
is that bad when you run a couple steps
you're supposed to be able to see them
you should have emulated on a steam deck
you're solving the waiting processes is
set up
Nintendo got you when it comes to stuff
like that because I want to play this
competitively so I can't yeah
did you apply for your Pokemon card I
can't I can't it's just it's just like
you know I'm not gonna say this is like
the worst ball Club I may have ever
played I do feel like they have you know
some good fat especially the auto
battles you know how nice it is just to
send my Pokemon like destroy everything
I don't have to do anything
but this is the part I don't that's you
know something I'm really opposed to how
Pokemon is you gotta think about it you
got this this this this creature and
they're intelligent because they can
talk right so they could talk they have
conversation they have Pokemon they have
souls you go on the field you see these
dudes minding their business living
their life you grab them
[Applause]
for you hold up hold up it's even worse
than that so what they've done in this
game in Pokemon Scarlet is they have
scenarios where you'll see like the
first form like five or six around the
last four so pretty much they're
insinuating this is the the mom these
are the kids you could just run up to me
like your kids are mine
breaking up families and see what they
gonna be later you judging them
[Laughter]
yeah pretty much uh I will have that
review up next week for the people that
do care even though Stitch isn't one of
them
after that I'll probably I'll be
reviewing cholesterol protocol and then
I'm done I'm done for a cup take a break
like I've been pretty much reviewing a
game every week
and I got to thank you yesterday for
popping up yesterday to do the community
streaming I thought I was just asking a
question he's like yeah man let's go
see like I just woke up at 10 games
they're in the mail order in the mail
they're in the mail okay yeah well I I
actually I didn't say you guys
don't don't yeah don't send me don't
send me because he means the email
yeah
don't yeah it's good because I spoke to
Sinister and we doing our sharing back
and then I gotta get one of y'all cause
when the family plan come out
yeah okay yeah yeah I got somebody had
two dependents so okay
the families were five okay
we have to do it yeah
you know the crazy thing though I think
most of us are prepaid to like 22 like
20 yeah
oh okay well find out what your
situation is because I know you he got
dependents he claiming on his taxes yes
I don't think that would affect game
sharing because we don't know how it's
gonna work that would just be a plan
like I don't think they're gonna require
you to make your home someone else's
just to do that
and if it breaks the past relationship
I'm very curious about that they may try
to make a whole new thing with the Xbox
game the way I would say is of work like
Netflix like the app handles all that
you go into the app it will say who do
you you said emails just like how they
do uh the Nintendo one you send an email
and then you accept it through the email
that's that's how I would assume it I
just I just think it's going to be
different for a purchase again purchase
games is going to continue to work the
way it has been yeah yeah this just
could be Game Pass all right we'll see
how I go anyway that's been an addict
pretty much I'll be good yeah that's
that's it man and of course we have our
most technical gaming Lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single player
selfish experience and also the South
Street Davis the Lord of clarity and
lower patreon of the iron bank always
coming in one minute before start time
oh it really is it's really low as
always lately last too much beats as
always
so to continue the Pokemon
[Laughter]
so my nephew that my nephew is Pokemon
addict like he's he's in there so he's
like he's like deal I went to see him
yesterday um and he's like dude the game
the game came out like wait wait wait a
minute is he is it out yet I'm like no I
don't think so I'm looking at it I don't
think so
his birthday is next Sunday oh but you
oh wait wait it's out already yeah it's
out already
I'm like bro Pokemon doesn't come out
for you till next Sunday for you
it's next Sunday he was like but I could
get the digital version and you could
send that one back no no no you can't
so he was like because the fact that
it's out in the wild that he can't
but he almost it almost slipped his mind
but he managed to see it and that was it
do they got the Black Friday for them
what Nintendo be like yeah
it has the Black Friday right
they pretty much have like signed a deal
that says we always get this
talk about these other deals these dudes
talk about Final Fantasy they talk about
all these other things
no no this is the this is the fight this
is the fight right here this contractors
King listen you supposed to be good
today because Nintendo ain't completed
hell no this is the this is the wildest
fraud alert uh what because you know why
why I hit a hypocrisy
common knowledge see I'm ignorant to
this right here right okay I'm thinking
this was Nintendo first party and this
is like I think this is like God of War
yeah
no we need
to get made on
YouTube I'm talking to chat every uh
Nintendo expert Donald taku Nintendo has
33 or a 33 stake along with game freak
and the Pokemon company
[Laughter]
no it's crazy
you know what's crazy this is how king
would do it it'll come to Xbox he'd be
talking all that smash yeah and they'd
be like oh it's not all Game Pass I
ain't playing it exactly
The Game Pass DMV
so you already running at that better
performance so the series X comes
running anywhere other than just one
spot yeah yeah I would actually agree
it's really bad y'all want to talk about
Destiny that's the real Pokemon it's
like the real Pokemon Master this game
and when I say it runs bad I'm not
exaggerating yeah it's horrible Tie by
Stitch
[Laughter]
what else did I do so I I played a
little bit of Summerville I could not
finish it because yesterday I had to
leave my house when I didn't have to and
so I I lost a couple of hours there so I
can't finish some of them you know I
just there was something that I I had I
thought I had to do and then my sister
informed me late that I did not have to
do it and I'm like great thanks
yeah yeah so I lost something I've been
I'm there too I don't know what you
thought I could talk about it because
real quick yeah
it's a decent game yeah all right let's
go let's go let's go so my quick
thoughts on what I've seen
um aesthetically beautiful in the same
vein in the atmosphere the fact that
there's no talking or whatever
everything is kind of told with
environmentals and sounds and kind of
reactions and the fact that the graphics
are so simple but still conveying like
that that really beautiful sort of like
the atmosphere and scariness of what's
going on is great the only things that
I've noticed up front is it's not quite
an inside level right it's not quite
there because inside inside the super
well is that even the Cinematic stuff
flowed from one thing to another song so
easily you knew exactly kind of what you
had to do yes the only time it really
felt gamey was the puzzles right here
when you're moving from place like when
the game starts and you run you walking
around you don't really know what to do
yes and you don't and you don't get any
on-screen indicators as to which sign
posting like you have to just kind of
figure out like probably everything yeah
yeah so that takes you out of it a
little bit although in the beginning the
person you're controlling it would make
sense that they touch everything right
right yes yes so but beyond that I
haven't done too much more story-wise
whatever uh what I've seen yeah what
I've seen is crazy so okay before we go
into that real quick vampire survivors
egregiously what not in Game of the Year
I'm sorry that game is crazy I'm sorry
against Chris I'll say that I'll say
that and then uh shout out to uh audible
because I was uh I listened to Cliffy
B's entire book control freak yes Cliffy
B story is fun it's funny because the
Dude is reading it it Cliff it just
sounds like Cliff talking like Cliffs
like I did this and I did this whatever
but then there's a point later in his
life now where he's like he processed
all everything that he did he's he's
glad for it he's glad for you know where
it's left him in life but he learned a
lot of hard lessons and there were
points in his life where he was you know
he was he he went from the nerd who was
constantly ostracized to the man got it
and and it it went to his head a little
bit but in a lot of ways that attitude
is what made Gears become what it was
what it is right right
um did he apologize to Microsoft for the
stupid move that he made oh come on
experience that he had to get Oh you
mean the law Breakers
died but no but he said he said the
truth about that what he's like he was
like they had the bag he didn't have the
money he they had the bag there was
nothing for Microsoft so he was like yo
until we get viable plaque he the
easiest way to when you have a brand new
game like that remember back then there
wasn't really a No Game Pass right so
the and that's kind of the only viable
way to for lawbreakers to come out yeah
so it was this thing of like hey the PC
platform is where it is the easiest
inroads right and then PlayStation gave
him the bags I was like okay cool he
said beyond that if the game does well
happy to put her on Xbox but it wasn't
something that was viable right like it
wasn't and and you know money ain't good
money yeah and then the game you know
the game came out at a time remember
OverWatch came out and ate lunch
and that was it like all it needed was
the oil
not to mention no yeah what is the thing
it's still a thing is not right yeah but
it wasn't just OverWatch it was pubg oh
it was it was fortnite he taught he told
the story about how um
no no he blaming people for his game
being away he told the story about
fortnite where he he essentially named
it fortnite that was him right and this
was Hugo is ridiculous
he was very you gotta just hate them
because he sound like he he shame he
blaming everybody but yeah
they did not read the book he burned a
lot of bridges so certain people wasn't
looking his way when he needed a lot a
lot of a lot of the things that he felt
he did in Korea everything yeah goofy
beats in a different place and like
really like he he acknowledges all of
that and he's like hey I'm still in a
great place in life but mistakes were
made and I acknowledge them yeah so um
he talks about how Rod Ferguson wanted
to kill fortnite
what Rod wanted to kill fortnite he was
like it was just like yeah it's great
but not because Rod is Rod is gears
gears Rod is about gears they had
fortnite early
well what do you mean well yeah that's
them that's them right epic right
foreign
from the jump Rod wanted to kill it and
if they had just killed fortnite none of
this none of that would have happened
right so interesting stuff but Cliffy B
like he he realizes the mistakes that
were made and he's just like I'm glad
that a lot of people like he's it's
weird though because it doesn't seem
like he's as tight
with epic people as he even was with the
people that were at boss key that you
know obviously lost their jobs on there
but it's it kind of seemed like Tim
Sweeney at the moment he had a heart to
heart with Tim Sweeney like yo man like
he wanted to be he he wanted to elevate
even higher at Epic and Tim was like
this is the deal we made this is what
you're getting and it was it was good
but he wanted more and Tim was like nah
that's not what it's going to be I need
you to make a decision are you I want
you to be here but if not you need to go
um and he did that's what Cliff decided
to go arrogance but after that it was
crazy because Tim was at that point not
that he considered him an enemy but
after that it was like Tim is like Tim
was like his his mentor Father Figure
remember Cliffy B lost his father early
in life okay clippy B lost his dad at
15. oh man so Tim's Winnie was like a
big father figure
it was very much kind of like his
business now yeah like he when boss key
was going down he poked some people from
both key like and then clippy B on
Twitter was like stop taking my people
dude like yeah yeah I think I would like
that yeah and then Tim Sweeney um it was
just one of those things where it's like
very much once he left it's like
business is business if I gotta take you
down kind of that's right
at the end at the end of it he doesn't
he doesn't really say where his
relationship stands with Tim Sweeney
right now baby
but um yeah man interesting book
interesting story like it made me I had
to go back and see all the like all the
First videos we saw of your ears like it
it kind of got me amped for it yeah so
good stuff good stuff no doubt man I
gotta read that I will I gotta listen to
that book on my nighttime drive you know
just to get to get laughs in because
my vision of it it gives you a different
Vision because my vision of it looking
out was Reckless dude
Sweeney yo he had his law Breakers in
the background yeah I'm gonna do with
the gears you know what I'm saying yo I
need more steak in the company you said
well you can leave you know that right
well that's how the conversation goes
live from Cake dude TV
I built this place you go full apart
without me saying you really think so B
I see you why are you approaching my
people
you let them go let them go please
sounding Microsoft money they don't want
to recognize greatness
you don't recognize greatness baby Sony
recognize we got greatness over here B
the funny part was when he when they
when they first showed OverWatch and
everybody on the team was like we're
dead we're dead because they were they
were yo because they saw it and they
were like they need they were doing a
hero shooter
um with with
um they had guns that had multiple sort
of firing type of uh different type of
firing yeah you know alt fire whatever
the case may be and they had abilities
right they had just decided on the
abilities thing so at that moment this
is something new like oh okay we're
doing something new whatever and then
OverWatch yo you know what's crazy in
the games industry think about that like
you working on the title you don't know
you're in your little salad you don't
know what nobody else doing you think
you have to do it's the hottest and then
whatever the next game breaking industry
shifting game comes out and you see the
trailer for it how does that feel in the
board rule when you see the trailer
hello
so people like
Cliff probably will only experience that
like once or twice you know who
experiences that almost yearly cool Call
of Duty because they're always three
years behind yeah they say oh no we they
don't care about this anymore but we've
been developing this for two years but
then the sales sale
but anyway I gotta catch you what's the
name of the book that uh
[Laughter]
you're gonna stop disrespecting me I'm
gonna walk I'm gonna take my company
B we would love to have you yeah we will
have kids sit out in that show listen
Cliff not for nothing I do appreciate
everything for uh for guess what all
this stuff is just jokes so if you know
us you know it's just jokes but I know
you was arrogant beat oh and he'll tell
you as much oh that's what's up yeah
and of course we have the Incredible
Hulk of this aka the Cliffy oh hey did
his thing he been talking awfully
the prophet of Xbox mommy King of the
statues demands nothing less than that
premium experience it is the leader of
the fraud alert movement
beloved Lord King how are we doing sir
I'm doing Versace Versace Versace
out here it's crazy over my body
not good at all
all right but on a line of note I
finished Somerville okay oh and you know
what's crazy so I'm playing God of War
and then Summerville pop out so you know
my game yo listen
I know I'm a complete fraud I ain't
gonna sit here in cap I'm not even gonna
sit here now what you doing not one time
am I gonna say God of War look
graphically better than I mean um
Somerville looks graphically better than
God okay not even though at least you've
established that yeah
he's going somewhere else thank God we
got over that hurdle no no no
definitely going somewhere I was just
sitting there and it felt like I was
going through the motions same I just
want to get to the next big battle Yeah
the next big plot point in God of War go
to this little area Achilles stupid frog
people and these little things coming
out the ground search and see what I can
get do these little fake puzzles do the
same stuff over and over again right
same DLC stuff let's get over here let's
get to the point right and then
Somerville comes out
and I'm I'm like okay I'm thinking about
inside yeah I'm thinking about flashback
I'm thinking about out of this world so
my mind is racing with the possibilities
of what the game could be right so
there's no there's absolutely zero
dialogue no nothing real story you got
to find out and figure this out and it
unfolds in front of you this is the most
frustrating game that I've ever played
right and I'm gonna say this is the
reason why let's go this like you said
there's no prompts on the screen there's
nothing
this dude is walking and it feels like
this was Atari Jaguar game oh damn this
feel like this was an Atari Jaguar game
flat shaded polygons with multi-level
stuff and they added up and they brought
it up to this level like they brought it
up the head but this feels like an Atari
Jack I really feel like why are you
driving this way
more type of field
and
it makes no sense the story that is
being told
[Music]
you're left
feeling empty and Hollow oh so you end
it damn I ended the hell out of it and
I'm going back to the last chapter
because I did something and it said
something at the end to make you say oh
it must be more Indians okay oh God
and I'm just like
this dude is the worst man alive
he is the worst man alive damn first
and then and this is gonna be some
spoilers for you guys I don't know I
don't I don't care
um
I don't know listen y'all didn't know
the first game told you atreus wasn't
his so if we're gonna sit there and tell
me
you know why it did because God listen
he came to how she was already with
child
[Music]
y'all just didn't play it again y'all
too busy with the graphics
delusion they call him the spoiler kid
but you know what yeah they they never
said that in the original one yeah well
he don't look like him
yeah
so I'm sorry if y'all dudes want to talk
look at babies and think they're yours
looked over at a trash it was like he
ain't seen nothing shout out to me
he looked at more reporters
the kid is yours he just spoiled the
same thing two weeks two weeks ago
this thing is y'all did why did he call
him boy right he looks over at this dude
it don't look like him don't act like
him I'm like no so if y'all want look at
let's say you a Caucasian dude and you
got a little black baby looking just
like me
oh you're a black dude with a little
white baby he looked just like me no no
no trash doesn't look like Kratos at all
don't act like him
oh man this is that was stupid so I
listen and I didn't even finish that
game to know anything and what y'all
talking about it was just me knowing
that ain't his kid okay so uh anyway
back to this game yes
he wakes up
he's like the world is crumbling his
family is dead he wakes up the only
thing there is his dog yes I said mother
effort what like you just left me here
like this is what this is what you do
all right me and my dog
me and my dog
how you leave the only thing that was
with you I said this is when I was
through with the game because I'm a dog
lover oh okay okay so I'm like this is I
was so through with this game and I said
I just gotta get to the end of this
stupidness I gotta get to the end of
this stupidness because
they left you but you gonna leave that
you I feel that I feel like okay I
didn't feel that his disconnect with the
world and why are you doing this
I don't know and then I get to the end I
gotta get to The Last Story okay I gotta
get to the last I gotta get to the other
endings because my ending was so whole I
felt Hollow with my ending and I said I
need answers here because it's stuff
that goes on in that game yeah yeah yeah
like what's going on it's a wild stuff
where I'm at I'm like yo what is going
on
it's crazy the most frustrating game and
it left me feeling the hollowest and I
can get back that time so honestly if
y'all gonna play God bless you got a
break for them
it can't be a spoiler the king is dead
wrong also he finished it thank God all
right cool don't sound decision oh thank
you slow mo I have no idea but I know he
don't look like him see I can believe
anything that work they have no DNA back
then
I wouldn't get to me I'll tell you but
what I will say is there's flashback and
Ragnarok at the point that that proved
you dead wrong
but you got to play right that kid don't
look nothing like him they got oh they
went they got they went back to the sex
scenes they showed them
that's on a different website
sorry king sorry King but that's on a
different way yeah anyway has that been
it okay
so shout out to everybody who came and
saw me and addicted to our thing
yesterday I was late it was a
miscommunication with addict an attic
listen attic don't play if addict's
gonna do something he's all the way in
that's why I love this dude so he's on
and I'm rushing back from the storm like
oh my God he lied because I was gonna
tweet it said he laughed I said so let
me get over there and we got into
fortnite it was just me and him shout
out to all the cowboys that didn't want
to show up you know to help us out
so yeah yeah yeah you want a Super Chat
yeah
[Laughter]
so it was me and addict and we got a
chicken dinner regardless regardless we
put the Hammers down yeah
could be argued king islamo would have
been part of the group we wouldn't have
got that chicken
I said only fans Kratos Kratos be
playing the ultimate child support I
know they Savage
King is like where is the trail let's
just goatee
[Laughter]
anyway
we're gonna talk about this misogynistic
egotistical dude I'm not gonna say not
gonna name him Kratos Jr
it ain't gonna be no entrance so you
gonna tell me this dude is so arrogant
so over the top that his son ain't gonna
be a junior
have the gaming ninja himself the
Shinobi 38 minutes on uh 38 minutes of a
child support and Adrians
spreading that realness in the realm of
the IOP not tell you what you want to
hear what you need to hear shout out to
Mr Maddie plays yo go check us out man
we had an amazing one with uh Joshua
from uh
ultimate all free feeds go check that
out we did it in fact three episodes we
got another defining dude talk about
what's going on with the game awards and
obviously the next chapter to do them
comes diversity to all app but yeah go
check that song man but he did his thing
he talked about a lot of stuff that's
going on shout out to George shoya the
legend as far as our destiny been
rocking shout out to umontist I got
Travis talking about all the latest
crucial update they finally got a PVP
ranking system like Halo it's coming
thank you thank you thank you
competitive PVP finally Bungie it's good
to see you go back to your roots and do
the system that you invented and put it
in Destiny finally so you think that has
something to do with the fact that Sony
owns Evo oh I don't know I don't think I
don't think so because
Evil's fighting isn't it yeah Evo's
fighting well I mean competitive
shooting in PvP could be in it but
Destiny's never treated himself like a
serious competitor it's just too much
with the supers of the abilities to
balance it's just way too much I think
they've gotten out of that realm but
they are going to come out with their
own live service game that you know
supposed to be PVP focused on the hero
shoe to focus but whatever so that's it
as far as games beat Panthers
that's a long game yeah a lot to say
there a lot to say that I'm gonna tell
you about all right so let me tell y'all
off the rip this game made for everybody
this is a niche game right in the sense
of I highly recommend if you're gonna
stick with it just get to the first
murder the first murder will let you
know
because in the beginning yo I'm not
gonna hold y'all know I was just like I
don't know there's a lot of text this is
Jay looking like a Bible verse
looking like I'm in church right now I'm
like what's going on I I remember King
you got me I got a call from my soul
because I was capping so hard when I
heard the announcement for the game yeah
right so in my mind soft so I'll show
you about to do a double lay Chevrolet
I was like oh man we had grounded Vibes
the streak is in Jeopardy of good uh
undefeated gay shout out to slow mo
better than disco Elysium good question
I actually asked Josh Sawyer about that
on our interview
um I'm gonna give disco the edge disco
still I give it because also disco got
voice that's just me but that means a
lot yeah I will say
this game had its hooks on me from the
first murder on
this game is so well written well done
and then the class not only the classic
who done it it's got the skill checks
it's got how you talk you don't know
what's going everybody got their own
motive then it's this wild serial killer
leaving notes and threatening and
embodying people it's it's like a game
of Clue yes and it got horror then you
start really uncovering the Mysteries
and I would tell you right now like this
Joy I'll go for after about an hour to
get the arch style I'm like yo this is
fire like they do little certain words
they blink their eyes they do little
things and they're expression when they
mad scared or like you can see what it's
like the peasants they got the really
whack font with the they look like they
broke no education
and then you got the real dude that'd be
pontificating and when they angry they
worried to be shaking and they be doing
it so it's so much Cutthroat going on in
this game everybody got their motive and
to me the culmination was act two Act 2
was so far because you're literally in
the middle of a full-scale beef and War
and they like yo they like cake if you
don't solve this we're gonna blow this
church up we go we go and the church is
like yo we think it's such and such and
y'all better we gonna stop this
revolution it is so deep for the time
period if you're a fan of medieval if
you're a fan of the culture if you're a
fan of who done it if you're a fan of
the clue if you're a fan of that like
this has some of the best dialogue
choices in the game I've ever seen in
the sense of you could have three
different things and some of them kind
of seem similar to say to somebody but
how you say it and where they align
could change how you convince somebody
to your side to get them to do some
sheisiness for you some dirt for you yo
game is fire I care for it's point and
click I'm not gonna sit here act like
it's something Massive Action game this
is not going to be for everybody but I'm
not going to front when I got to the
first murder I was like no no this is
fine I could not stop playing dead yeah
if it wasn't for game pass this game
couldn't come out no he did say that
yeah without game pass it could come out
and the thing about it what I like is
that
we got to be real and this is no
disrespect to the AAA bangers I love
them but like for me where I'm at I it's
if you keep playing nothing but that all
the time you need that palette cleanse
that's just me like how we talk about
Summerville we talk about pandemic we
love God of War nobody's disrespected we
love the Elder ring somebody disrespect
it but if you're just doing open world
baby daddy simulator yeah it's like just
for me like I needed the palace so I'm
like yo I'm invested all I say is people
give it a shot give it a shot if you
don't like it it is what it is totally
good but God could be they got one so
salute to that playing Somerville
playing some both King addict I mean um
this game got potential to be amazing
the controls get in the way you don't
know if you're going back forward some
can I kick it up did I get to that point
with the stupid bucket yep the [ __ ] that
is the worst puzzle going that puzzle
doesn't make logical I don't feel that
puzzle was earned I was like what are we
doing about the water thing yeah you got
to get this and I'm like this doesn't
make sense because I'm like why do
things ain't doing what they supposed to
do and then I'm like all right whatever
man yeah don't get me this this other
part for those little things yeah you're
gonna throw the control bro there's two
puzzles that I'm like this is what I
feel and maybe I'm wrong soft because
the person who makes this they're called
jump ship right and I apparently one one
of the guys jump ship
right I'm interested to see how played
that played right now here's the thing
to me this is what I have I'm talking
foolish I don't know no details this is
my theory the dude who made the
atmosphere inside the graphics this is
him this is him so we like him right we
like yo-yo but yup you need polish I see
why the other Duty your polish and and
and the puzzle technical what to
interact with you don't know it glitched
on me three times yeah it's gonna be
three times I'm like come on SO Jaguar
energy
so that's no it has that flashback type
of yeah like energy and yeah yeah man
like that to me it is that thing of like
you know it it feels like it was
appearing that needs they need each
other that's what I got that's not the
case because it played this gameplay you
gotta understand play inside and this
has all inside the all-time old game
like straight up so yeah that's what I
feel they need they need to work it out
they need to get back together let's say
this in this game's defense yes
um
inside is completely really linear yeah
this game is sold three dimensions and
it's in its execution yes as far as
going into the background going into the
foreground going um elevated in Heights
going under I will say caves some of the
set like this guy's level design is
exceptional it's crazy because some of
the set piece I go for I like when you
got to the Sound Stage with the concert
today
yeah no doubt and he definitely the
worst father ever he the worst parent
ever like yeah but look try it it's it's
definitely a good game it's just I think
the story guy jump shift yeah
it just you see those levels inside is
still here this could have been amazing
I was waiting for it to get great yeah
you know what I'm saying yeah I'm gonna
say last thing though is when the dudes
with the jet pack the dudes the red so
that's why
let's get it hello
I love stuff like that because that game
Viking has that yeah and you see
something in the background
and it's running running with you like
oh there's nothing scarier in a game
with his nose like it's but it's not the
data it's not telling it I hold your
hair and you see an imminent threat in
the distance
you know what's bad cause they usually
got red light or red tape and a red eye
yeah why you watching me so like what
you doing back there and you know it's
on yeah so I will say that's where it
gives you that out of this world but it
just slightly misses The Mark with the
technical issue so that's that and then
um shout out to yeah that's what's up so
um shout out to Kai shout out to say
shout out we got y'all server for
Grounded we oh yeah we gotta log in it's
gonna be late yeah y'all went in there
and messed with the world we took the
base we took the base
yeah they had to clean up yeah
I don't like when they go with like
Sinister I I got to call them Sinister
the great yeah
maximize something someplace else
no but listen I'm responsible for y'all
y'all water I got y'all do collector
we got y'all they got indoor plumbing
bro I gave you I probably I got y'all
canteens I like going in the forest in
the bucket
you know what I I'm about to I'm about
to load up the Xbox see what you guys
yeah
when you put on the server take off the
friendly fire please
yeah you why can't you go back in the
house what you mean go go back can you
go back in the house oh we got to get we
got to do the story that's the story boy
to get back into the house you can never
go into the house but not grout is fine
it's like um Honey I Shrunk the Kids
yeah that house is far away
it's like it's like Lord of the Rings
track away
from here to Queens yeah I'll get there
see like hopefully I gotta speak to you
can't go how far I am good where in the
end and then I want to do play Tales
next and try to get that out but anyway
I gotta do that too see the same way
that you said that but I want to finish
God of War yeah so I gotta I gotta get
back again
so did you guys play so I I didn't
mention that I play a little bit more
right so I you know I got to the I found
that found that individual we're looking
for right it's the beginning I've never
seen a more broken person in my life
yeah
just just keep playing he said keep
playing there's more we got over 400
people and I got 136 likes please walk
in the house wipe your feet please let's
do it appreciate you appreciate y'all no
doubt so we all good on that um yes last
uh let's get the super chats huh oh one
last thing on the Cliffy B book I forgot
like before he went to no before he went
to the boss key one of the big things he
admitted he made a mistake you know Rod
Ferguson is known as the closer yeah he
gets there so Rod he gets things done so
he goes to Rod before like wanting Rod
to come on to boss key and Rob was like
cool that sounds great
I wanted to be a me and you think like
we you and I together at the top of this
making something happen and Cliff was
like he's like my ego got in the way no
and I was like I need this to be and he
needed some somebody like Rod we could
be talking about boss key today yes
he needed somebody like rod and his ego
got in the way he admitted that and he
was like that was one of the biggest
mistakes I ever made I told rod and I
this has to be me and Rob was like bet
no doubt peace
and then shout out to him giving people
ultimatums and them dudes taking it the
other way yeah and he was like what
valued himself at every instance yeah
but again he acknowledged it he was like
yo things might be different because you
know Rod is about getting stuff done and
he's No Nonsense in that regard and he
didn't realize at that moment that he
needed that and it just it went left
that's crazy he didn't want to share the
back that's crazy
could have had a lot more of like the
industry stuff better than
lessons you're supposed to learn in life
right right we got Rod back
we got drawn TJ five dollar Super Chat
morning Lord so you think Microsoft will
buy Crystal Dynamic and idos and saber
uh and saber front embracer after the
ABK deal
saber front Embrace I think there's a
chance I don't know if it's a high
chance but I think there's a chance but
I think he's asking here is that if they
would buy embracer they're not buying oh
not embrace it no oh no no I'm talking
about the the companies from Crystal D
saber yeah
like over there they talk about how
things are going much better now that
the crystal ball his people
yeah get security codes are not this way
yeah I don't know embracing
look at all this stuff yeah oh my God
yeah yo we got all we got to do is put a
roof
no you got to do catch it right there we
got the water we got we got we got a
filtration
attack from Titan and build a wall
we got smoothies in the corner yeah
it's like you rent the Airbnb and then
you go in there redecorate yeah and we
had to build the wall because the
spiders be coming through from up top
you know what I'm saying so we had to
build the wall you went into the Airbnb
you said you put it for a month and then
came back with wholesale renovation
heated heavy 505 remember for 30 months
thank you so much Lord red and gold
about to go down in the Lord's a
football fantasy league let's Mother
Love and go you talking that fantasy no
doubt then we got Paul AFC five pounds
the Lord's best way to increase PS plus
Subs as Jeff Keeley the nominator cat
simulator as game of the year yeah
like one of these things is doing this
yeah
that we got Big Mad Mo remember for 29
months big up to the Lords and around
Happy Thanksgiving to all no doubt yeah
oh citizen Talent we tell we killed two
wolf spiders fast we cheesed the hell
out
yeah we got Sith Lord remember for two
months two dollars what is everyone
doing for Thanksgiving eating way too
much yes and I don't really celebrate it
but I'm forced too
I'm just having a get-together
we got a Rel member for 12 months uh we
got the fraud alert up quick boy oh boy
what's your name
I said baby daddy similar no step daddy
simulator
yeah cradles doesn't seem like a cabron
to me so I don't know I don't know what
he would do this cradle does not not the
first series
uh rank PVP for Destiny and no new maps
or old DL uh uh Destiny one Maps
this is Rel against them you say oh yeah
yeah PVP for Destiny and no new maps no
they got one new map is bad the map
situation is bad I agree continue then
we got THX 1138 two dollars from chat
give Game Pass we play games not watch
qte movies
there's plenty of game playing God of
War I gotta sit there and say they ain't
no game today bad ass off Kratos is not
a that's a Spanish word
I just said he's not
uh
oh yes he is moving
then we have five dollars okay [ __ ] but
I heard that stranding is one of your
game of the years no don't do that don't
do it I've told people that's a
glorified FedEx sibling all right I'm
slandering you know what I'm saying but
I will say I mean it's literally
delivered across the world like the
world that is the game with a postal
system I mean let's be real but I will
say kajibas they said the edit gets
better I'll finish it on a steep deck
I'm I'm still going on it continue and
we got Shinobi kicks put the crested
then we got Stitch member for two years
ten dollars I can't wait to hear all
your thoughts on the Sony Awards and
other game shows
let's say also if I see any of you
switch kids on DMZ I will take your dog
tag and lastly have a great holiday
everyone today
yeah draw TJ again I sent the super chat
before the show started I think you guys
might have missed it yeah we got you bro
is this the one is this the one the
morning Lord you think Microsoft will
buy because they got to do one I think
that's the car yeah yeah
we got okay
hold on let me roll back a little bit
because this is what I love to do as I'm
reading I like to add more pragmatic ego
remember for 37 months good afternoon
Lords and Ladies can't stay gotta watch
my uh eight and one Eagles catch the
replay well wishes for everyone have a
great week remember to be kind to one of
them yes yes always remember that
absolutely there was some discourse
under into it yesterday I was not happy
about it yeah yeah
people that I'm disappointed in that's
all right that's what we're talking
about that JD gamer 20 loss of attack
shout out to the Lord just feel out
there making moves of what collecting
tears and crushing dreams look to the
left and hear the those ponies scream
six months left before so when he gets
gobsmacked five more years before it's
over here
objective is always something
oh get your people now he he out there
he right though
you on the money with this one oh man
he said you think you missed one
maybe I missed slow-mo let's let us know
which one we missed just tell him was it
yours because he got a smiley face I'm
thinking it's him or somebody or some
some slanderous thing we're talking
about carrying me on a fortnight oh yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah oh yeah okay inside
the book bag let's go no more back slap
five dollars to the chat I'm down for
fortnite next time fellas I'll put
addict in my backpack
tell him I'm okay at Fortnight no no
he's more than okay you saw that chicken
dinner is up it's live in full effect
see and I can say this he killed his guy
I killed my guy it was two P it was it
was two teams left it was us against the
other team attic took care of his
business so I gotta respect my guy my
his Gun Works sir no doubt no doubt then
we got game anomics member for seven
months at this point Phil should just
make a t-shirt saying Call of Duty was
there on PlayStation and sell them on
the Xbox merch site also wear it in
public yeah that'd be funny
that we have like Metroid member for 14
months Elden ring is one of the greatest
games I have ever played in my game of
the year also Miyamoto turned 70 this
past Wednesday long lived the greatest
yeah wow you got to start acknowledging
the uh the mortality of these greats yes
to the legendary draw on TJ 2010. hi
King David
what's going on
hi guys
play with my Jason I haven't seen yeah
why do you invoke the name
they showed up in the park they showed
me and uh what means
they said something like I love to play
fortnite with Saul
thanks let's bring that in not
acknowledging it I said vote that Dave
back
there we go Lord
now I'm telling you he is
moving along
then we got Smitty Smith remember for 34
Buzz salute to the Lord in the chat and
peace to Prince Parker lady Rosa and
Lord I dizzy rest in power the book of
Acts
still miss you always always we got Lord
whiskey yes
look Still rocking one of them on for a
little bit you know let me see let me
see drawing TJ five dollars per chap
Embrace us talking about selling off
some studios is what I think that's why
I asked that super chat before Oh okay
the way it it sounded like you were
saying they were gonna buy embracer no I
saw um
I believe those Studios already sold
okay illegal said we sent a super chat
at the beginning member freebie but it
seems to be missed just make sure
everyone has I did not see if it's right
in the beginning then
but if it's a member chat that's a
member chat was a member chat let's see
yeah take it out I'll see if I can help
out find it just just at solve what you
said in the member chat yes yeah that's
it yeah okay hold on a second
even when you go to to the the place
yeah where they store it YouTube where
everything is the member chat aren't
there yeah Elliot put what you said and
then tagged me let's say YouTube at its
finest I know brother yeah tag me again
and uh and I'll read it so just just
write what you wrote that will give you
your bars off get your boss we got Tyson
Lewis member for 13 months what up fam
Dope Show is always King uh Davis Garcia
who you got and blessings to all the
family in the realm
uh tank versus uh that's a good one I
gotta see all the way up to it you gotta
say Ryan Garcia is taller uh heavier and
arguably faster right but who has the
most experience who hits harder who can
get into the ribs this is the proverbial
fight of Mike Tyson versus there I'd say
it Muhammad Ali
um in the sense that if you look at Ryan
Garcia he fights with his neck up like
Ali the problem is he doesn't take
punches like Ali right so this is the
best fight that we can have now with two
young dudes that's not afraid to let the
O go and get in there that's what we
need to see more of tank versus Ryan is
a true pick em fight because
either one can end the fight with one
punch yeah that's a great uh Super Chat
and I appreciate it but we'll definitely
be covering that fight
we got Queen trash gaming one dollar
thank you so much wow
is that is their middle finger yeah
I gotta go to Twitter and put in Queen
trash game in the city that's crazy then
we got akw55 super chat Murray cradles
the results and more Murray like ah
Murray Kratos the results are in and you
are not the father
they always call him Murray instead of
Maury
yo cake CJ said Garcia's left hook is
fighting him and once tanks up a cut
land is over time
this is honestly the truth but again
we could say anything we want the fight
has to play itself out okay let's watch
the fight
if you if you would have said this was
Andrew Tate versus Jake Paul
YouTube like yeah that's what he is we
got fonze gaming member for 19 months
that's what I voted for straight both a
game of the year best action adventure
game hey it was in both categories I
hope it with both that awards show is
whack
y'all know that's how certain Fanboys
don't talk smack about grounded very
interesting keep it up guys love your
work hello from New Jersey
oh shout out to my man except ghost in
the Xbox Xbox suspension pass shout out
to the Lord I shout out to the ghosts in
there play stupid games with stupid
prize okay I see you funds messy anyway
we caught up
had calling on recently shout out yeah
shout out to y'all man I see y'all doing
that thing anyway the poll results I
ended people spoken to the question with
the critically acclaimed God of War
Ragnarok which game do you have as your
current goatee of the year the winner of
our three-way ILP poll with a commanding
72 percent of the vote was Eldon King
remains champ by transforming the Soul's
genre to open world critically acclaimed
group coming in at second place with 23
percent of the Void was Boy Ragnarok
comes in late with outstanding graphics
and compelling narrative to win the
goatee award and then last place at four
percent of the vote was I don't care
We're Not Gonna Act Like satanic Animal
Crossing Cult of the land was not out
here dominating these streets Lord solve
your slanderous thoughts on this poll
from last week uh I mean I Love Cult of
the lamb
um I I get Elder ring for sure it should
get it Elder ring is transformative I've
never seen the game genre that that
appealed to such a niche crowd just
opened up to like everybody in One
installment
um but my personal gameplay is this too
it's vampire survivors and where's
seafood at or c4x
like I said one of these things is doing
his own thing and then just letting them
belong there
then we have Eliot slow mom events you
didn't have to make it a Super Chat bro
30 uh I forgot I don't know that
comments I forgot what it is I'll look
it up sorry uh happy to be back to
listening to podcasts and gaming after
round two of covert hope yeah
for weeks mentioned me for a week happy
Sunday and week to the realm and
Thanksgiving to whomever celebrates it
likewise glad to see you feeling better
man good to see you man always have an
informative always call it he said his
new Israeli uh shekels the shekels
that's right shackles yeah I was gonna
tell you he's out in Israel okay I want
to give a shout out to um uh Donna taco
and them that we played uh uh grounded
with them
tell them I made the place nice for
y'all yeah we we didn't
hit though or yeah it was it was him
Gallery after you left he he he played
oh so you didn't like it when I was
there I'm gonna come first maybe maybe
that's what was going on
yeah right we got around 2000 we chat 25
of God of War is on a boat telling ghost
stories
don't lie I'm so sick and tired of that
boat anyway I want to give a shout out
to miss grandia in the chat I've never
seen that name in the chat before but
Grand look Grande is one of the goats
oh yes absolutely I've never played that
game yeah grandiose though amazing that
was for the scent uh the Saturn the
Saturn Japanese and then it came to
PlayStation uh on over here okay yeah so
that's the one I was that's the game
aren't they remaking those so I believe
so I think they are yeah
or you can play them in the PlayStation
Plus because they got a whole bunch of
old games you can call here we go then
we got Lord Metroid two dollars tears of
the Kingdom Game of the Year 2023
guaranteed I mean he probably not wrong
I don't know that's something else
really comes out and probably not wrong
it's different yeah yeah all right we
good
a lot of information dispersed here a
lot I'm not gonna get through every day
the interview is extremely long I'm just
going to touch on a few points obviously
uh one of the major subjects was
PlayStation and whether that it would be
or Call of Duty would be long term on
the platform he said that he's open to
making that commitment to Sony and The
Regulators there's like Call of Duty was
still on PlayStation on a long-term
basis they currently agreed he talked
about Keystone about the price point
where they were ads that revealed they
talk about the star field red fall delay
you know in reference to they're going
to be in the right call giving them the
time some real strong comments about
mobile and you know saying they would be
kind of unattainable without mobile but
a lot a lot did Cody I don't know how
much of you guys a chance to catch any
of this interview but um yeah a lot of
nuggets here so I want to get your
thoughts fill outside and clarifying I
guess the overall thing was Call of Duty
the importance of Mobile you know and
re-emphasizing things so when you act
broad addicts what you think about all
this stuff from Phil
uh I didn't catch the interview uh this
week I'm pretty much playing Pokemon but
uh from what you described he's
literally did an interview on everything
I'm not interested in so uh e Stone
don't care about that uh I don't care
about Call of Duty don't care about that
either mobile I definitely don't care
about that you love mobile
okay
I'm doing Pokemon mobile
like the typical mobile market like
Candy Crush and stuff like that I'm
really interested in that uh but I know
a lot of people that are interested so
you know I hope you guys enjoyed the
interview uh but until they start
talking about a vowed star filled and
all the stuff I care about uh you know
catch me outside
no he just basically said you know the
delay was in referee felt it was the
right okay so when he talks about
Starfield catch me outside
all right so that that's it you're
nothing else you can't find I just I I
at this point unless like they're
talking about games I I don't watch
these interviews anymore because it's
just like it just seems like you know
Phil was very good I regurgitating the
same information in 18 different ways so
it's just like to me it's like you know
I I'm sure a lot of people make content
about it and that's probably why I'm
such a bad YouTuber because I didn't but
I refuse to talk about stuff I I don't
care about and you know when I saw the
cliff notes on the interview I was just
like okay this is is this all like and
what I found out that was all it's cool
but it's just it's one of those things
where I don't want to hear Microsoft
talking unless it's games at this point
because it's just you you got some stuff
like you know uh look look at the game
of the year just that that speaks for
itself no Microsoft IPS on that list so
I don't care what a bikini mobile was I
don't care what cloud was I don't care
what mobile was give me some games and
then you could talk about other stuff to
me so
don't run the business
no that's where you at that's where you
at and I gotta respect it you know say
he's like yo until you you hear about
the where the next first party games
2023 and all that that's where you at
all right no doubt what's up what's up
you get a chance to catch any of this
interview yeah some of it something not
the whole thing but again to me the the
funniest thing is like you know I like
initially I do like how they talked
about like the how they structure stuff
and Microsoft and how he kind of like
when you talk about his position within
the company he says like there are a lot
of CEOs within within Microsoft there's
a lot of divisions are sort of run
independently of the bigger umbrellas
right
um so that's good because it gives them
a level of autonomy that I think that if
it were just an umbrella directly under
the big Microsoft Banner that reported
every single thing obviously he has to
report to Satya but at the same time he
does have a lot of autonomy within that
and I think he mentioned LinkedIn has
their own CEO as well like so that sort
of stuff is very cool to see those kind
of Corporations were structured aren't
they it depends
but you would say the CFO of the large
corporation or the CEO of the large
corporation there are smaller CEOs
within Microsoft depending yeah many
bosses right but there are still CEOs in
their own right so that's cool it's the
mini boss for LinkedIn
is like the overlord
so that that's interesting because it
gives you a little bit of insight on how
decisions are made right and it is kind
of siled off a little bit which is
interesting to me because a lot of times
we talk about oh Santa gave him this and
obviously that is probably true but the
fact that a lot of the day-to-day stuff
just really is focused in that Silo is
interesting
um obviously the car the Cod stuff is
because it
it's just I'm tired of it you know uh
everything everything that I predicted
is the truth
the Cod stuff is they're gonna treat it
like Minecraft as much as possible it
it's just it's easy money it's easy
money and all the speculation that we
had about hey do they try to finagle
game pass on that he's like no no no
we'll make you a native version that's
it like the only thing I want to see in
practice is again is if as if like all
right since we you know we're bed
fellows and you know Jim comes down but
like hey man how about you know not not
doing this game pass thing with God and
when Phil laughs at him that's what I
want to see that's what I want to see
what the reaction to that if you want to
see the high disrespect right because it
is one of those things it's like listen
bro like we own this it's going to games
I might have had a little more you know
I might have been a little more willing
to listen in right now but it really
does feel like
it's going to be interesting when it
when they're able to put it straight up
in game pass
because that is a differentiator no
matter what you say like it's over
because we're gonna see we're gonna see
you're gonna have your Fanboys that
aren't leaving their platform no matter
what right Mass Exodus
are you implying that as soon as Call of
Duty comes in the game pass let my
people go
oh my God
[Music]
the river will park
we're standing there with the staff
no you're not doing the nose he ain't
doing red stuff he didn't do the stuff
he threw a game series s on the floor
I let my people go
I can't I can't with you that was stupid
[Applause]
you know that uh that Meme with uh Phil
Spencer always used for the thumbnails
with the the series X like yes
imagine a Siri a a bazooka series X that
shoots series esses
ridiculous
it's a Merry Christmas
commercial oh yeah I can't with y'all
man yeah so so that to me you know again
that that is that thing where it's like
hey it was it's an obvious thing it's
money in their pockets handled with this
they're they're going to continue to do
that and then you know the
acknowledgment of another thing that I
said what that that the the big get for
real for you yeah yeah for real for real
is is King because
the free agent has been signed yes yes
they got the deal done you know we got
do it all daddy
gave my man a bag but I'm gonna tell
y'all that you back you know because I
think what they what they you have to
come to realize is that you're not going
to convert casual gamers people that
play on that phone yes with core games
correct it's not gonna do it like it's
it's very few people that will look at a
core game that are used to just playing
on their phone quickly or whatever and
be like I need this on my phone right
it's not gonna happen you have an easier
chance of of getting a core gamer to try
a a mobile game right
um so in order to be able to sell Game
Pass in the way they need to Game Pass
has to evolve into encompassing these
other types of game experiences
enter King it's a king all of a sudden
now you got Candy Crush under your wing
that just makes money hand over fist for
no reason
yeah so you already have something that
makes money hand over fist for no reason
and imagine what you can create under
that and continue to again Evolve game
pass into something that provides true
gaming experience right now we we kind
of Marvel at the diversity of Game Pass
right we really do Marvel at it imagine
adding another tab in there that's just
mobile stuff that really that'd be
saying and again it gives the
opportunity to make even more higher
quality mobile stuff that doesn't
necessarily have all the gotcha stuff in
it whatever
and again it just makes the entire
package more appealing what that's going
to do to the price who knows right we're
expecting it to go up anyway at some
point fire
but I tell you that that is the kicker
because when they talk about we want to
reach 2 billion gamers
you can't reach 2 billion Gamers with
just core games and Game Pass you
already you already said they already
told you that the console Market is
essentially plateaued you have some
groceries
it came across the gate he said
so
[Laughter]
again Game Pass is the Trojan Horse for
that for the mobile games and for them
to really really bring in that money
um and they they got it that that's key
for them that's key for them if they
want game pass to be everywhere the way
they want it to be it's just it's
otherwise you're just gonna Plateau off
in the in the uh in the console space
and even the PC space although it's a
lot of growth there and they're getting
Game Pass PC to more parity with console
uh game pass but it it's it's still it's
still not enough yeah they need that
mobile yeah they definitely need yeah
bigger footprint there no doubt a lot of
bars Lord King any uh stand out quotes
from the Dominus that you were feeling
you mean from now Xbox situation
where is my situation it was all premium
baby
like like addict said
he could say something 17 different ways
but it's the same thing right he's very
very good at that yeah and I gotta find
out if this guy studies psychology
absolutely yeah he has to have a
master's degree in Psychology because
these dudes be really thinking they
getting gotcha moments and it be what he
want to say
so you know it's a game pass uh what
what are we talking about with this
PlayStation performance as long as
PlayStation is in existence
yeah that part
so his little chess pieces is there
right as long as he's in existence man
Call of Duty Advantage
so if his whole outcome is he don't want
Call of Duty over there right we don't
know his intentions inside right oh he
said this right I'll let you go that's
what I'm saying we don't know the
intentions aside but we know what he's
saying verbally right verbally as long
as PlayStation has existence y'all don't
ever have to worry about PlayStation I
mean
um
you will have this as long as they're in
existence so if if in his heart he don't
want it over there y'all not gonna be in
existence very long
it means it means see this is the thing
you gotta find out the intent behind the
words right the intend behind the words
yo don't worry about it man as long as
y'all alive
this this is technically it as long as
you still draw breath
I will send over a bagel
next year you get a bagel Bagels Call of
Duty you get a bagel with cream cheese
and jelly that's you every year don't
you worry about that set my stacks my
racks and we good we feed the village
every year for you
the moment you stop breathing
[Laughter]
the moment you no longer draw a breath
no more bagels for the squad
can I read the exact quote though okay
yeah go for it all right let's actually
get to the give some context into this
stuff like you know this guy get to that
part as long as they breathing
I understand the Optics of this deal we
we want to make and I'm totally open to
do this a contractual commitment to
solely for some years that says okay
we're going to continue to ship Call of
Duty on Playstation I'm totally open to
that no issue at all the idea that we're
going to write a contract that says
forever does it make sense to any lawyer
there is obviously a business
relationship between the royalty
exchanges and other things you're not
going to give up any ability to do what
you do need to do and the flexibility
with the business of the future when I'm
saying things as as long as there is a
Playstation there was no implied threat
at all I hope there's a PlayStation
forever I do I think PlayStation okay I
know where you're going I think
PlayStation Nintendo are great for the
game again history however I have been
consistent in saying that all I mean is
that at some point you have the ability
to run the business and not just the
console business it's not about pulling
the rug out from underneath the
PlayStation 7's legs at some point
saying haha you didn't write the
contract long enough
there's no contract that can be written
that says
okay so all right
you talking to the dude with the shotgun
yeah
I didn't mean to threaten you
if you perceive this shotgun as a threat
so you still say that he talking from a
position
from the only position of power my God
like he's like don't worry about it
don't you fret over something I had no
control over but listen again like I
said as long as you draw breath
he's literally the dude that controls
the oxygen levels
trust me telling you I'm not threatening
you but
if you so happen to expire
we just don't have no longer no more
obligation
and then he's saying oh I don't want
y'all to think when PlayStation 7 comes
up we just gonna yank it out y'all might
just expire before that
so why are you worrying about seven you
gotta get to six
unfortunately I don't think that's gonna
happen yeah you mess yourself
is that what you say Phil Switzer met
listen I'm I'm I'm the dude okay he has
two dudes on the shoulder right you
probably got Cog on one shoulder with
wings
don't do that Phil let them have it it's
good and I'm on the other side I'm like
strangle them
first you don't hear that person
probably is it's probably Eric
so uh what I got from that interview
again is
he's trying to you know ease fears like
when you have dudes from the CMA coming
out talking about uh they looking out
for the best interest
of I don't know who the CMA is looking
out for the bad sisters of my
PlayStation
you know when you have people coming out
saying stuff like that it's it's kind of
scary so again
it's it's radical fanism and he's trying
to qualifies and and let you know don't
worry man as long as you guys are still
alive y'all have Call of Duty don't
worry about it my prediction is y'all
ain't gonna be alive much longer anyways
so the fact of the matter is this
conversation is mute but y'all falling
for the banana in the tailpipe and he
keeps selling you the magic trick the
magic trick is Call of Duty right y'all
keep falling y'all keep looking at it
you keep watching his hands and he
already did sleight of hand already and
slipped and came pause and
when that happens that's the real
the Candy Crush like I think you said it
eloquently called
you can get a casual to probably
try or a hardcore to try a mobile game
right casual you can't put like Kratos
on mobile and expect it to sell to the
Candy Crush dude yeah okay the question
women
when I say when I say dude I know what
you mean yeah I'm considered as all you
know I'm not giving you agenda so it's
just the fact that they're going after
the Casual dollar because the casuals
are spending and it's it's such a good
price point
King has already built the mobile market
how they want to build it in order to
get to that and remember Microsoft is
going up against apple and Google's
mobile market store they're building a
mobile market positions going around in
these streets so it's really not about
what a little Call of Duty a little Call
of Duty for One console manufacturers
they'd have nothing that can compete
with that that's life blood type of
thing
and
Phil will tell you Call of Duty ain't
all that serious B that's not what we're
talking about here what we're talking
about is the true acquisition which is
really king and you know to go with that
thank you
it is so dope
but you know we're trying to get here
and
even Jim knows it that's why PlayStation
went out and got a mobile group a mobile
Studio to boost that aspect of it yes
it's vision and foresight maybe
PlayStation is still stuck in Tradition
in the Eastern tradition that they're
not going to be able to Pivot Jim is
trying to make them pivot as hard as
possible yeah right he's trying to make
things as competitive as possible so the
stuff that he's doing it may go and buck
tradition but he's doing it for your
best interests don't you that's why
y'all can't get rid of him
so maybe it might be too late because
Phil is already transitioned he already
ascending so once certain things land
who's first you don't care Call of Duty
is deaf it ain't no console
I mean look it's a lot of bars in it
I'll jump in Greater view I mean
everything y'all said soft said I agree
too and you said okay I always find a
sense of this is the re-emphasis tour
this is
like kids it's like almost a psychology
we gotta get it in your head what we're
doing same things that we've always been
saying you know the PlayStation thing
they treat the Call of Duty thing
they're treating it like Minecraft right
you know from a business standpoint it
makes perfect sense let's like soft said
because you know in the beginning I
admit I was the first to I get this
wrong too I shout out to Jess Gordon
because you know I thought that they
might treat this the way they treated
star field with them but that's the
acquisition it's like yo we'll take it
off to drive subscriptions but at the
end of the day it's such you have such
an install base on PlayStation and let's
be real like soft said there are going
to be people who still stay in that
ecosystem there's nothing you're going
to do to get them over there will be an
exodus door onto Kings Point two though
I will say okay there will be
Call of Duty players that when the
proposition is made right and it's like
okay you can pay the 70 or you can go
over here and if you already have an
Xbox or you can you get in that entry
point with a series that's or whatever
there's going to be players that do that
too so I'm not going to minimize what
that is but why eliminate a base that
doesn't come over right yep and then you
say boom you pay the 70
we get our percentage or whatever it is
all that cash hand over fist you know
what I'm saying and that Revenue I do
got one thing to say sorry
about the Keystone
um yeah I do care about the Keystone
okay I don't think Keystone first of all
I believe Keystone is done right I don't
believe Keystone is at the price point
that they wanted it and you know that
that much has been said so it's been
shelved until a financially viable at
that point I honestly don't even believe
it's that I believe it's more Sinister
than that I believe because it's
something that you said that made me
remember this what's up and I'm I'm
gonna get to see that right now let's go
after this ABK deal goes through and it
will go through because they're very
very confident
y'all can cry all you want it's gonna
happen
you're just gonna cry more you just
gotta say I don't care but um after it
happens after they have Call of Duty in
there for those people that don't want
to make the transition for a hundred
dollars they pick up this stick this
Keystone stick this Keystone thing this
little device get a controller and get
your Call of Duty on because remember
now Call of Duty costs a hundred dollars
for the whole uh the hiding right now
right so you get let's say you go get
game pass on King with the Keystone for
a hundred dollars
Call of Duty's already in there with
Game Pass so you purchased a device that
came with hundreds of games including
the game that you play all the time
right for the same price you would have
normally paid for the game itself right
yeah you and then there's gonna be
people who don't buy console and then
according to what we hear shout out to
just go into Windows Central you know
part of another reason why I was the
latest they want to be able to come at
that price point like you said 100 they
wouldn't be able to have it with the
packing controller almost think Google
Chrome with a controller and game pass
on it then you know you got you you
coming in with that such a lower price
point like that that could if you hit
that Mark you could get another Market
that wouldn't have necessarily
traditionally yeah buy a cops I was
going to say is the the the rule bear is
the apps they want it to be the thought
process is like how they get a chrome
you got your Netflix you got your stuff
you got all the apps on it with the
media to get the people as well that's
the pushing yeah no I just you said
something that like reminded me to that
point yeah and then AJ did mention the
Keystone because you did Keystone was
part of it because everybody saw it on
his dress uh on the show yeah and was
like oh it's coming it's not not right
now but it will be yeah they I think
they're trying to the tune and get it to
where they're comfortable price point
was because you can't have the series s
and it be similar price yeah it makes no
sense you defeat the purpose of the
Keystone so I thought that was
interesting there's a lot of bars in
there that besides the re-emphasis boss
was the play State I mean the Call of
Duty you know the mobile market he went
hard though yeah he went hard yeah okay
get at it I just want to interrupt the
podcast real quick yes please uh this
was just tweeted by uh gaming Forte look
at look at this dude this uh someone
bought a series X and then asked to buy
all of this for the next customer in
line wow that's amazing that's crazy
shout out to the table
why why wasn't I in line
that that's probably like a thousand
dollars worth of stuff that's nice to it
happy holidays with the Forte out there
in them streets but um yeah so I thought
the other thing that was interesting you
know besides that the mobile saying I
think he's like they would be
unattainable without without it and that
um yeah how critical it is again
re-emphasis of the console Market
um of how like you know I'm actually
just going to read the quote it was
crazy he was like um basically this is
just a place where if we don't gain
relevancy as a gaming Brad we're not
alone and seeing this over time the
business will become kind of
unattainable for us we're not gonna find
we if if we don't are not able to find
customers on phones or any screen that
someone wants to play on you're really
not going to get you're really only
going to get a segmented or Niche part
of gaming when you're trying to run a
global business and then um yeah he said
the console business is shrinking
because the overall business growth and
console stays relatively flat same thing
with PC he mentioned tencent how they're
one of the biggest gaming companies in
the world their revenue comes primarily
for mobile they talked about how
Microsoft is actually probably most
likely buying Candy Crush Call of Duty
but with Diablo having all those Diablo
mobile under their franchises under the
acquisition so the king part is huge for
them and that's the thing like as king
is saying the banana and the tailpipe we
understand what Call of Duty is we
totally get that but at the end of the
day they don't have a footprint then I
know we're gonna get into another Topic
in reference to storefronts but the plan
is if Microsoft then opens up the
Microsoft the Xbox storefront and you
pull them Joints off them other
storefronts and they exclusively to your
mobile store for the hottest games
whether it be Candy Crush whatever
they're just those mobile only games
because to your point okay a lot of
mobile guys
not necessarily going to want this big
ridiculous AAA type experience they may
have that Elvis That's there but the
reality is they want to play some quick
in and out to them right and that's the
big that's the growing Market that's
where everyone's trending to like he
said about 10 seconds so if they have a
footprint there now they talk about the
long tail for them they talked about the
PC growth I thought that was interesting
look it was a lot of bars here I mean
this is the reality sometimes I feel
that the industry as hardcore Gamers we
struggle with and I think that you're
not getting a race That's a hardcore I
think a lot of people spread a lot of
misinformation and fear about that this
is just planning for the future that
when it goes there or if it you have
your pillars in place you have something
ready to go and the last thing I'll say
is about the the Starfield delay for
adding I thought that was interesting
you know basically saying what you know
Tottenham needed the time you know so
ultimately it's the right call we all I
think the thing that's lost in it is
that as much as people are disappointed
with 2022 for the first party standpoint
and it we all like let's we're not going
to minimize that but it was the right
call right you don't want the games to
not come out looking and being polished
and doing what you know what they need
to do so look I thought it was a good
interview I thought he re-emphasized
everything that he needed to
re-emphasize and um yeah as far as the
uh the con situation you know I I
anticipate them to to do everything to
maintain parity give everybody
listen I mean yeah good you can get the
game but we're not gonna hold ourselves
back for you that's the fair I'm
actually playing the best over here the
reason I'm with King is because Sony
plays dirty why shouldn't Microsoft yeah
yeah like Sony locks down all this
content locks down this uh you know
Harry Potter content locks down Square
Enix stuff like I want Microsoft to have
that same energy to their competition
because their competition does it to
them yeah
whatever it's not messy it's just I want
that energy returned I just I just want
it to play at its efficient Peak you
don't remember like when we got Street
Fighter yeah or Super Nintendo we got it
for Genesis you it was left up to the
consumer to say which one was the best
right so they go and they made the best
version that they can make for Genesis
Turbo graphics and Super Nintendo and
the consumer
decided which one was the best right it
wasn't no could you imagine back then if
Nintendo said well this is the parody
Clause
because we don't have blood in this
sweat so yeah you can get the game but
if your console can't do 60 frames per
second
and this one can't uh you ain't holding
nobody back
it's gonna be called the Xbox tax
I want them I want I just want you at
heart are you at Hardware maneuvering
for the series no I know what I wanted
what I want is you see because you have
these PlayStation dudes just run out of
there 12 12 flops I don't see them you
don't see them because in the contract
they put back there hold on back
King is I I feel you King and I and I
know you know they got to be corporate
and stuff but the petty side of me the
one that had to wait years to have
certain guns on Destiny the one that has
to buy PlayStation for Square Enix games
the one that has the uh you know the
Tactics Ogre King can't play that on
Xbox I want par to be once Microsoft
have that you take one of
I want them to be able to fight up to
their capabilities right there's a
reason why Phil went out and wanted the
most powerful console right and it's not
oh just for our first parties it's a
show in third parties the superiority
that you have over the competition yes
you can't show the superiority if in the
cause it's parody right right oh if this
joint over there could do a little bit
more of volumetric fog right ah buddy
you can't Implement that because we have
to be Perry no
do all the volumetric fog education
remember the first Call of Duty you
don't remember that joint that was on um
XBox and Nate joint had the volumetric
fog remember when you shot and you saw a
swirl we was like whoa look at this Xbox
doing the thing and they did it in the
PlayStation and it just went through and
he was just like oh man this PlayStation
this PlayStation 3 ain't it right so
what I really want
let the games be developed to the
maximum to the capabilities of every
machine and let the chips fall where
they thought
let us let us see if I mean because if
it's about competition oh here we go
oh hey man I came up with the young Odin
Road come on man you know speaking of
which he did there was a bar really that
I thought was interesting where he was
kind of like you know how he got named
the CEO of Microsoft gaming division you
know he elevated felt elevated to the
thing he's actually it was they asked
like was it something you can't pay for
that you you know kind of put on the
table he was like nah it was something
young Odin Satya Nadella you know was it
decision he said it was all him during
the the time of the um talks of of the
Activision acquisition yeah so that
decision came from up high I also
thought it was interesting how marketing
the way their marketing teams were
situated prior to this thing wasn't
really in conjunction with Xbox because
you know sometimes we'd be having issues
with their marketing we'd be like yo I
don't promote enough so now they've made
some internal shifting and I think this
guy some name Jared West or something
so yeah with Cinemax possibly but I mean
I I think but overall X now that Xbox
has a seat at the table and he's the CEO
of Microsoft gaming the vibe I'm getting
is the marketing team shift is now to to
focus towards Xbox game because
marketing from my understanding was
still kind of global for the whole of
Microsoft right yeah so yeah that'd be
interesting so so it was like how I said
what
young Odin looked outside and said oh no
no it was like you said no it wasn't a
young squabbling
[Applause]
after his next Conquest in the yard
they come at night it did go down how
you say I give you that it did go to how
you said the last thing I said he did
throw a shot though because he was like
um when they would talk about the
inadequacies
and all that and he said well last time
I checked before that like I hear nobody
I didn't hear Nintendo sending out any
complaints about today
let's be real here though is because
Nintendo feels confident in The Prodigy
they put out and sure you know the
little bit of colleges they might lose
when they do occasionally put them out
yeah uh I don't think they've done it in
years yeah they're like look we don't
need that PlayStation needs that like
it's not something it is small like they
they make probably
they make what some companies make just
in the 30 they take off the top for by
selling uh uh Call of Duty yeah I'm
gonna say it's more Sinister than that
what you're saying he had a little
switch that was on his shelf right yeah
yeah yeah so somebody in pocket with him
yeah I'm not letting that switch for his
shelf thing go I don't care what no
nobody said yeah with the squad they
like don't worry we're gonna let that
deal go through it does it help kill
them
by all means does it help so questions
did he say anything specific about how
they're gonna handle once they have
control of King how they gonna handle it
sorry they don't never have control
what's the about
[Laughter]
how do they handle you know Candy Crush
or whatever whatever products they have
on these on Android on apps
you said all right so in addition you're
buying candy crusher company people
think it's about Call of Duty but it's
about he said absolutely in addition the
number that is not in the Candy Crush
King number is Call of Duty Mobile in
Diablo mobile which are big franchise
that exist in that Activision and
blizzard bucket that are also major
players on phones the idea that
Activision is all about Call of Duty on
console is a construct that might get
created by our console competitor and
some out there so he just talked about
so you want to talk about the storefront
specifically is your question right how
they handle it is it going to be are
they I'm sure they're still going to
sell a piecemeal right but is it how
does that work you know the whole issue
that we had with the sort of Epic and
the whole thing about fortnite having
its own sort of payment structure within
Apple oh I see no no he didn't go from
my understanding he all right he just
said let's push it a minute he said if
you don't initiate customers on it I
don't see anything in reference there
just more about mobile the
um you know the rates the global
business but nothing specific on how
they're going to handle the storefront
at least I didn't see that maybe I'll
miss a chat let me know if he did say
that because I didn't say that
specifically yeah it's soon to be
confident that's kind of one of those
things probably maybe you can't even
talk about it until the deal is done
until it happens yeah it might be one of
them type situations but that's all I
got anything else people's will be good
super chats please
all right so we got not too many dude
we got Doro Taco member for one year
five dollars which I just finished
church and y'all just now getting into
the first topic oh we do because we do
over here we got JD gamer remember for
two years five dollars for chat we need
some grandia lunar civil Star Story
Panzer Dragon Saga Shining Force 3 Lost
Odyssey and blue dragon in our lives yes
to preach all of that yeah and we got
Suicide Kings remember for two years two
dollars for the chat this is technology
that King is hella messy yes
then we got drunk to learn
[Laughter]
my beard isn't done I'm messy as hell
drawn TJ two dollar Super Chat they also
get Battlenet yep that is an amazing
they definitely want to see how they
handle that they're gonna handle it well
[Laughter]
then we got Carl Andrews Junior two
dollars for chat Sony Sony lost lost
crash but didn't look back ratchet stays
yeah rat is gonna stay because ratchet
is owned by uh
that's crazy I can't wait for the first
commercial and they outside the Sony
building
there we go call Andrews Jr again two
dollars in the chat fight for your
exclusive Sony you won't lose
he's giving Jim some words of
encouragement guess what you're excuses
then we got Flame
all I saw them was in a pit
like Fight Club and young squabbling
come outside
and in this corner we have the young
Squad
[Laughter]
keep it moving stand up for Jim
you know what you sound like remember
how but we used to hate the Showtime
boxing us yes and it'd be like Ryan Ryan
yeah
[Laughter]
the Sony Awards and Pokemon being broken
are Hot Topics but you know what's even
hotter getting those moats to the bank
it's time for a Prime Evil
Gambit all right all right you know
what's sad we we stay away from Gambit
like like it's the plague but there was
a time when we were so addicted today I
remember when I was dead when Gambit
debuted it was me that's legary and a
couple other people we played it we
played it at E3 83 yeah that was E3 you
know what's funny I remember when they
had that when the lament first came out
and we were putting bubbles up over the
Primeval and yeah
my thing was the best game Gambit was
when you had individual clothes to close
the teeth and roll properties yes
well you can see Invaders when they came
in yeah and when they went away from
that I was like man
salute the back from the dead in the
chest I see you brother good to see you
yeah
but is the one thing I did play in in me
oh really yeah
I played Gavin I did play again all
right all right all right brother I make
you rich brother
[Music]
it's proof positive that Sonic fans
can't have good things man what's
happening in these
ah so the father of Sonic the Hedgehog
the legendary developer of Sonic and
battle in Wonder World
legendary at the legendary Valley what
the world Yuji Naka has been arrested in
Japan on suspicion of insider trading
wow
wow based on a trade that he made while
he was still working at Square Enix
working on said battle in Wonder World
um yeah so yeah so NACA and along with a
few others someone named uh taisuk
suzaki and fumiyaki Suzuki all purchased
shares and well yujinaka specifically
purchase purchased shares in a company
in a developer called uh aiming
that was uh going to is going to develop
and at that point unannounced Dragon
Quest mobile game called tact
obviously a big deal Dragon Quest
anything in Japan will be huge I might
pop also exactly so
um so not the other two people that I
mentioned I think in total bought shares
worth over oh nearing 350 000 knock I
think purchased something in the range
of twenty thousand dollars worth of
shares in the company aiming right
before this deal was announced
um at that point you know obviously
starting accusations of insider trading
having knowledge of this deal before
before it went public and um enriching
themselves as a result
so at this point yes usinaca is behind
blocks wow but insider trading
um just for clarity this is the creator
of Sonic the Hedgehog this is just for
clarity so inside of church let me jump
in this I'm sorry I just catch up with
falopy as a second kid this is very
disheartening
um
all right so just for the tab line
he's which Square Enix the Dragon Mobile
the Dragon Quest mobile game is about to
come out the alleged inside training
because we gotta be well he's arrested
he's arrested I mean yeah but yeah so he
might have he might have already
confessed right whatever he's been
accused
before you post business post bail and
leave Yeah man so um Danny okay that
comes out now the thing that's
interesting because remember we covered
this why I wanted to go for we covered
this remember when ballon won wasn't
received well yeah and like
he then came out with a whole statement
saying yo Square Enix is you know he
threw Square Enix under they don't care
about gaming because remember the timing
was the timing was you got he had got
removed right essentially yeah they they
you know whatever ballon Wonder World
was a mess right and it felt like it was
attributed to him and you know they
kindly you know set went their separate
ways like he is the Dig so I hear where
you going and at the time we was like
damn like swear just removed him like
that that's right because of the quality
they gave but the question is if you
look at the Timeline to when this game
was coming out and this alleged in such
I'm not saying it's an absolute
connection but it's very close proximity
to when the allegations of the inside so
what you're saying you're saying
somebody was snitching if
Square Enix knew of this and wanted to
protect themselves one would think you
would disassociate yourself
are you you're implying
[ __ ] so let me get this right okay are
you implying it
said parent company snitched the boy out
I'm not even playing anything I'm just
saying the timing is quite interesting
that he was removed coincidentally yes
at the time of this that that's all I'm
saying it's very interesting timing and
I'm very curious about it because since
then he had drag Square you know as far
as like they don't care about gaming
stop talking now they don't they didn't
give me enough time that's why the
quality of the game was and here's the
thing like obviously I'm in corporate so
it's like bro let me tell you them
inside like I have people have to take
training you have to take courses before
you accept the job is it affects your
employment or what insider trading looks
like not abusing your position if you
know something's about to come and then
like it is a whole deal this is what I
don't like let's go
we live in a capitalistic Society
you got information right it can make
you wealthy to get you out of the
machine but if that information is
coming from is
privileged information that only you
know so so let me get this right let me
get this right let's go Martha stew it
okay shout out to Martha Stewart again
prior knowledge that she was gonna lose
money she said not today Satan
they said they said
they said the woman for bed sheets to
jail they send a woman for pots and pans
to chill the cooking the cooking Queen
they said that the cleanest person to
jail for for saving her money right so I
got knowledge you coming through I'm in
the rat race I'm paying bills I'm upside
down on some stuff and the dude say yo
we bought this gift signed by what you
record
because they interested in my joint yeah
and yo it's about to be a come up yeah
you know oh God yo everyone out there oh
we're coming up is me in this situation
over here and I call you too I see yo I
mean y'all three I said yo yo yo
I heard about this thing that's going
down
no
it's gonna fix this right there we're
about to go on vacation no no
so y'all say all right
listen listen I'm gonna do it without it
this is not a guilty Consciousness
any information that you are privileged
to that is confidential
daddy the Republic does not know but you
know what the only machine you go into
is the machine of prison
you know what it feels like though this
is not a corporate structure this is not
this is not this is you you are telling
me I can't do something in the best
interest with for me this is knowledge
in mine who's snitching D this is the
problem somebody in that room got
pressured and told because
it's three other children like 350. this
is the thing right it feels like
okay it was like
like that was like the ring lid but he
was like yo yo y'all gotta go light yeah
I can't be going crazy like yeah no
doubt usually no doubt yeah and then
they go in they're like now we're about
a hundred three hundred thousand dollars
the red flags went up so they caught
remember oh so this is a story they
caught them first now it was arrested
afterwards right so who's listening to
do because the first two they got
pressure it wasn't off and it was like
yo so who told you about the trade
knock knock
it's a problem see Martha went out there
and it was Martha got arrested by
herself it wasn't nobody else with her
she did her thing for the best of my
knowledge oh she probably was the more
High proud profile individual there like
in this case the most high profile dude
there
let him go he
go
here
it would have been lighter plus and you
say you say he made Sonic remember Sonic
ain't Big in Japan like he is here
Sonic has been a us thing if you look at
the history of Sega Sonic in a lot of
ways was the bane of city of Japan yeah
because they were like yo why can't
y'all over here in Japan make something
like Sonic and make it be successful
over here yeah they're not necessarily
the biggest fans
right now shout out to audible or twitch
he said he said that yadaka is sitting
in jail looking like Sonic's Idol
animation yo you wow anyway
free my man
[Laughter]
he couldn't take the fee to go go to the
library here today uh listen like here's
a dick you you know you had square and
you're in a bit and you find out they
partnering with some company that's
gonna make a mobile spin-off of draft do
you understand I can request how big
Dragon Quest this is so if you know a
Dragon Quest mobile game about to come
out before anybody and you happen to
throw your shares over you said your two
beds over there and they go hard they
cash that one 350 okay what is this up
two people but like they think that they
did but that was that could that was is
a lot to make it like significant money
on the cash out
no I'm saying is it's not a lot in the
totality of it it's just the fact that
it probably all happened at one time oh
I get mine you get yours you get why
everybody buying this this with a red
flag is coming of course yeah you know
so you know probably was it's probably
homeboy all of his money they just gave
everybody the bread he's okay you you
spend this and it was supposed to be
like nine ten other people and they just
spent all of everyone's on what three
people and remember I told you to get
your family into it now you do all of it
it was interesting because at the time
we just thought the beef was just him
taking them to court over the how he was
treated about the ballot in Wonder World
and being removed but I'm curious why
this is not this this is this is real I
think you on to something I think yeah
implications into the situation it's
definitely High I also think that's that
squid probably told them dudes you might
want to look over here
foreign
[Laughter]
for
um what is it 2.8 million yen which is
about 20 000 ahead of the games
announcement right and then you say his
cash out would have probably been like a
couple of million maybe oh and then hit
the peoples every time the two people
the two peoples they purchased before
him the combine 162 000 says for um
which would equate to about 337
000.
was just trying to live the next couple
years and good and they try to cash out
that's the favorite thing
addict they was trying to get that stuff
in Bermudas
I just got one thing to say man you know
you ever get those inside things you
know what they don't want it but I do
we make sure when we purchase it we do
it in the corporate account
[Music]
if me and King are in jail is solving
Congress still doing the show they
snitch
and I want y'all to go to your nearest
authorities
we just didn't choose to defend you
should make me
we're upstairs
please
[Laughter]
get the next one
we gotta move all from that dumb
and go 17 two possible chat you did not
get dropping the best out of jail
mixtape
knuckles
yes Savage
not get our own documentary it's worth
it
kid making FBI work please
no this is how it happened if I did it
it's a hypothetical super hypothetical
and everything moving on it's like Ted
Bundy if I had if I if if I would have
murdered
it'd be hypothetical you know
hypothetically let's just say you know
this isn't on the record but but Coggin
soft helps us every corner of this time
you got to do it do it in a way that you
can be like we did everything as a group
oh we did yeah
[Laughter]
there's this Queenie looking guy in the
alley by my house with an Overcoat
asking if you need an nft
maybe some Crystal D oh wait that's sold
out shout out to Nova then we got CW two
dollars in the chat Sonics papa needs
bail fat
[Laughter]
man should have asked for Pelosi
playbook out here yeah
she just quit too crazy yeah we got ever
boy and soccer five dollars the record
show I don't believe the charges for one
second square has a history of throwing
the talent under the bus and in the
bushes free knocking free
knocker okay okay you riding with the
ball all right give him some rings
salutes a little all right we caught up
this is the third one yeah it was
already done we got you everyone wanted
me to read that one though oh yeah we
got him we got him he got it
for the record and let the record show I
don't believe the charges for one second
squares the history of throwing their
talent under the bus and it's in the
bushes
so yeah look the king's topic series
that's y'all a little man little man
outside price drop 249 for the holidays
you know same promotional product
pricing starts today as the on Black
Friday offer and um yeah they're
dropping the price of it um they also
have some about 300 I offer a new
Surface and all some other stuff
um the official promotion means that uh
Best Buy Microsoft store and other
retails will all be offered the console
at this promotional price Target is
evening bundling a 50 gift card with the
uh Series S deal so yeah little man out
here with a temporary price cut uh
series X will remain at 500 but us I
mean a king what do you think about that
and do you want let's talk about this
first and then we'll do the secondary
part of it this is what Microsoft said
[Music]
you said they wanted competition
what are you applying sir what are you
applying this is how it stopped what so
this is how what starts be specific all
right so
250 bucks little man little man black
Fridays oh this is hitting all over you
see the bundle fortnite bundle with all
this stuff inside this this it looks
fantastic it taught yay
just said yo even that it's 250 we took
50 off but we also Gonna Give You fifty
dollars so it's really 200 bucks
you guys right now are looking at
a precipice
because everything is indicated the
hollow the the holidays starts off with
Black Friday followed by Cyber Monday
rolling into whatever the Christmas
buying season what do you think is going
to be the most purchased console oh are
we doing that yeah Microsoft said we
don't give a hell about dropping the
price for the series X PlayStation and
stock don't can't play it's five now
they got the stock up here they think
PlayStation
any day are we doing it let's do it
let's do it let's do it
hold on hold on I just took your knees
this is for you this is for you
this is for you because I'm gonna send
this Lubriderm over to you right so wait
hold on hold on so here we go here we go
so if if let's set the parameters so
King you say it series as Black Friday
250. it's gonna win it's gonna win it's
gonna win Black Friday oh Black Friday
it's gonna win Black Friday but what
about MPD football no whoa Black Friday
if it when's Black Friday it should win
the month right so they let's let's just
do it look at that I don't care what God
of War talking about what's up you can't
get a lot you can't get PlayStations
like that you can talk about oh they got
restocks up here yeah yeah talk about it
later yeah real quick so what side you
want if we all do this I kind of gotta
go with King man like I really do like
even as a little man yo I'm telling I'm
250. we're talking about double the
price for a Playstation
yeah but that Banger only everybody who
really wanted that Banger really I
wanted it at retail got that Banger I
think I think you guys are
underestimating the power of that
I think you underestimating the prop the
power of cheap people cheap yeah cheap I
don't know man I'm done I'm down with
the economy 50 extra a lot of people go
do their Christmas shopping at Target
what about you ain't got that bread in
there you see that you see that
toothpick I'm telling you 15 kills like
it does is there any game pass because I
know they have a couple different
bundles they have one with like the with
the snowflakes on it that is the holiday
bundle but then they have a combination
fortnite something else
bro I don't know man it's a tough one
baby because again I don't think I don't
think the God of War thing is an issue
for none yeah nobody's trying to do DLC
like that [ __ ]
console on his own is more of a threat
than you know the combination of God of
War because I said the God of War just
doesn't necessarily appeal to the
non-hardcore like it's just yeah all
right
Series S gilded Hunter no that's
something different okay I just want to
say I'm looking at the the deals I want
to see what's going on what Best Buy
Best Buy I got something Target got
something just want to see what the
deals yeah 250 holiday console white
little boxes on it hmm it's gonna be
interesting interesting I don't know
what it is is when you go on for your
Christmas shopping you could buy two
consoles you could buy one you got two
kids even if you got one kid the only
people that's buying those PlayStations
was the dudes that was waiting for a
game that was worthy at a time anyway so
I saw it on my timeline oh god of war
came out I'm gonna go get that now so
you wait till like the beginning because
it was nothing right it really appealed
to you what God of War is still about
the November oh yeah good I ain't saying
that God War ain't gonna win games right
I'm talking about consoles
what I'm saying is removing the switch
from it just against the PlayStation and
the Xbox because to switch switch might
beat them all yeah we don't know what's
with you but let me ask what Donald
tackle says Sirius X has a bundle with
Cod is that true yeah yeah it's
interesting yeah that changes things
yeah there's a series
I don't I don't care what your parameter
is
however you want to freeze
I'm gonna tell you I'm in for all this
Versace Versace
and and listen whenever when when you
lose
when when Benji sells and then put up
the notes
and you ain't got to wait see I had to
wait a long you had to wait a long time
to get my knees I ain't gonna wait too
long
this is how the king get his knees back
in one fell asleep oh this is tough this
is this Lubriderm all over
literally said let's do November and
that's what I agreed to you know what is
it I'm just asking what is it he said
what it is yeah I said no I'm talking
about earlier when we were saying we
couldn't do all right Black Friday we
could do November and I said well who
would ever win Black Friday would win
November anyway all right well I'm
saying this so then then you have no
problem with going with Black Friday
then because if yo if your thoughts is
whoever wins Black Friday wins uh
November is the same thing right so I
don't know
what the series
[Music]
[Laughter]
it would be hard to validate who wins on
Black Friday is because they're not
going we're not going to get individual
numbers it's because they're going to
bundle all the series together
don't I don't care
[Laughter]
obviously you don't care how are we
supposed to get how many series they
bundle all the PlayStation I don't care
how they will slice it we tell the
numbers how we do oh my God
I mean but they're going to do the same
with PlayStation you have a 400 one and
a 500 one there you go
take it we can't act like the two is the
same though like because literally it's
crazy two different consoles versus two
different skus it's not the same that's
right and even Forte has said that the
amount of actual digital versions they
have is far less than the amount of uh
PS5 with the uh no you're right but to
your point you know
they have a system selling AAA bang you
might win this I mean you got you got
some information
I'm just I'm just trying to point out
both to Taylor I'm Blown Away you got a
fighting chance this is interesting then
if you got such a fighting chance then
tell me that November I just said it I
said you told all of November timeout
from your logic
you said he who wins Black Friday wins
November
so from your own logic if I just base it
on one day you basing it on the rest of
the of the 31 I mean the 30 days I'm
basing it off for one day right so by
your logic you said he who wins Black
Friday wins November my logic is saying
Okay so let's go for Black Friday be
like that's no doubt here's the thing
the only reason I'm hesitant to take
that is
I don't know how much they split going
for God of War's release title two weeks
before Black Friday
so so are you is it more attic and
concerned that there is a scenario where
Series S could win Black Friday yet just
because it's that PlayStation wins
November is that what you're implant no
I I'm saying that because they might
sell more on just Black Friday just
because they might have more actual
supplies because they've sold so much
throughout November because they God of
War right that's why I will only do
November because if they sold 30 of
their stock because of God of War
they're not gonna have only 70 going
into Black Friday
23 billion k n y's twenty dollars Sony
fan says PlayStation 500 yeah
PS5 been number one on MPD for a couple
of months and dollar and unit sales
beating series and the switch don't know
what y'all talk about right good so we
ain't asking for your knees I'm talking
about man all right so so I I don't care
nothing about what you talk about the
PlayStation 5 has been selling all over
like hotcakes but y'all can't find one
right oh stop it
we put out the numbers that Jim say I
don't believe none of those numbers
because he always tell you y'all not
enough anyway back to the real deal we
know what's outside and what's 250 bucks
my faith is in the broke dude
is in the Cheapskate my faith is in the
individual that is Frugal with his bucks
I know I do walk inside the store and
say I can get two series s's or I could
get this one PlayStation five and I
gotta make a pimp decision a pimp
decision is this if you don't need it
you don't want it if you don't gotta
have it you don't get it and those
people that need to have it already got
it and they got it when god of war came
out on the 8th so it has nothing to do
with the day after Thanksgiving that's
the day old and ruled by little man so I
know for a fact your needs will be
coming to me along with mine if you did
across that line so I'm standing right
here and I'm looking fine in this time
so just just do November then you feel
so confident I said Black Friday let's
go well I guess the best that happening
so we gotta move on yeah
it is not it's not wiggled out of that
way
you look up gamer to me
hip-hop gamer beat you though he beat me
in the game but when I told him let's go
bet uh line up for lineup he did just
like you
yeah the the card bundle definitely
changed my mind yeah that car bundle
would be crazy let's see Call of Duty is
serious right all right let's see what
happens
really quick
um I'm gonna be mad if if it does one
Black Friday
yeah
a lot of actors uh accusations the
street so I know you see the second part
of this the uh Google and uh saying that
they paid Activision 360 million to not
compete epic says epic is telling Yeah
Tim Swinney in the streets again
[Laughter]
what do we know about this song real
quick
yeah so apparently uh it is being
claimed that Google
that Google Play paid Activision
Blizzard in addition to A League of
Legends Studio ride games owned by 10
cent
um that they paid
um sums of money to have those companies
not compete with them uh in terms of
opening rival uh app stores that really
feels like it should be illegal I'm
gonna be realized
this is preposterous yeah so
um
so uh Lulu Chang the uh Executive Vice
President of corporate Affairs at over
at Activision Blizzard and he's also the
chief uh corporate officer I think was
like this is preposterous this has never
happened again something that she would
say
um but again I don't know man Tim
Sweeney out here just just dropping
bombs man I have one thing to say about
that if uh me and King ever get busted
for our uh for our insider trading
that's exactly the statement we're going
to say
this is possible
this is preposterous at the same time
picking up my phone call can you how did
they find out no no we ain't gonna talk
on the phone I'll be like I'll be right
there
so yeah the exact amounts reported were
that um that that they paid Google paid
uh Activision Blizzard or was going to
pay them uh 360 million dollars over the
course of three years and that they
offered
um
uh Riot 30 million for one year just to
keep them off their backs I guess
ah
I don't know man like it's it obviously
Tim Sweeney felt strongly enough about
this to take it to court so um
because they
it claims that Google sort of launched
they wanted to acquire epic games right
in order to kind of take eliminate that
competition
um and then it also claims they kind of
wanted to team up with tencent to sort
of bombard and kind of hostile kind of a
hostile takeover of Epic um so again
this could be just Tim Sweeney sort of
defending himself and and and kind of
counter-attacking but to counter-attack
with something like that and to and
imply that collusion is happening uh in
order to uh a
inhibit real competition right and B in
order to swallow up one of the other uh
sort of gaming companies that have that
has a platform for selling yeah I don't
know man I I really don't know like Tim
Sweeney doesn't strike me as a type of
person like well okay let's be clear
they went it seems when he went out
and started a fight with apple that he
knew in some in a lot of ways he was not
gonna be able to win
but I kind of knew that already he just
wanted to have the fight I just want to
know how many bridges this man has burnt
he doesn't care because he's you know he
got fortnite money he doesn't care
now this is this is what's weird to me
like I just don't really know you don't
out and out make this type of accusation
like when you you know
with the Apple sort of lawsuit it was
like that they indicated they are
attempting to do X Y and Z and you put
you set forth your facts as to why you
think that is and you you put it into
the public forum into the court and then
they decide right this is different this
is flat out saying they did this they
lied they are cheating they're doing
this and
I'm almost like
it's super snitching in a way that like
it strikes me as something like dude you
like you know how you know what happens
to you if this turns out to be
completely false
like I don't think so and that's the
thing right like it doesn't strike me as
Tim Sweeney would bet the farm on
something like this because if you if
it's found out you made this up dude
they're gonna bury you I don't care how
much money you have they're gonna bury
you so it's something somebody lying
somebody lying and um I don't know this
is just super interesting
sorry yeah you're right somebody lying I
don't know who I don't know who it just
doesn't feel like it would be Tim
Sweeney like I don't know man so this
Tim sound like a stand-up dude to me
since that whole clinical event
situation listen I'm I'm 10. Mr Sweeney
oh look you gotta see what's gonna
happen I got very little balls on this
um
this is a damning acquisition because
then it's basically saying that Google
is paying off people not to make a store
to compete with them with them yeah
that's insanely
accusatory like that is so cool
what some might say frowned upon what
happened
oh God what sounds like somebody else is
doing the same things that this other
company has been paying people to keep
stuff off of other platforms and doing
things as well are you implying to
Google and Sony have similar traits I I
say they have a bloodline that is pretty
strong you know what's funny to your
arguments Google remember to jump after
that they say that Google is not liking
the deal with the Activision Blizzard
that was the rule yeah somebody seems to
be swimming in the same Waters
I I I I see it my my thing is everybody
has all this outrage for this
where's that outrage for the mother guys
it's doing the same practices this is
this is real stuff man I'm just saying
it's already interject but no you're
good I just see similarities and then I
see uh people saying one thing for one
oh
how could Google do this how if if
Google really did this this is a problem
and we should really score you Google
Google is back see it's all about who
you like and what you're willing to
tolerate and take from see a lot of
y'all don't like Google a lot of people
don't like big Google because you can't
stand the search engines or you can't
stand how intrusive they are or whatever
practices that you feel that somebody
has more money y'all always look at Sony
as little Sony all little Sony doing the
best that they can you know they don't
have money like that they can't fight
Microsoft like that so they need to do
these tactics they need to to to to to
section this off and use their money to
block their I have to this is what
little Sony has to do what's up with big
Google doing the same thing and what's
the problem the complaint also alleges
that in March 22 Google entered into a
similar agreement with 10 cent for
approximately 30 minutes and on with 10
cent Holdings on Riot games makers of
the hit lead right also exploit Ryan had
also explored launching its own app
store a spokesman so basically epic is
saying that Google is hitting people off
to that all right and not compete with
them interesting interesting I don't
know what's going on I believe Sweeney
Activision comes out They Came Out
Swinging them they like this is nonsense
they can swing away they like they said
we've confirmed Google has never asked
or pressured us or made us agree not to
complete what the apps compete with the
apps I mean we've submitted documents
and testimony that proves this
to me
why would they come out and say yeah he
right it's like yeah right no that's
what I meant why would they come outside
like when's the last time you saw
someone caught with the hand in the
cookie jar they're like yeah that was my
hand yeah you guys definitely yeah
as many PR speak as possible trying to
get around that yeah for sure I think
the thing about this that seems fishy to
me is the low numbers like yeah I mean
30 million to Riot what is 30 million
dollars to Riot like it it's not a huge
deal even the 360 50 million whatever to
um we don't know when this happened
though maybe it was a lot earlier and
Ryan's lifespan or yeah I don't know
you're laying down on right when they
saw the bills piling up it's like I got
30 million
what I think he's interested is
Microsoft's rolling it too because it's
not against soft that's maybe why they
just straight up denied it too because
it wasn't enough money
it's gonna be interesting now with
Microsoft trying to acquire Activision
Blizzard with this because we know they
got their plans for their own store yeah
this this mobile store is about to be a
battle going down yup I know you go okay
yeah yeah it's about to be about
a little bit a lot of moving Parts this
is what accusing that one Epic trying to
remember epic trying to shake up the
industry with the Apple store and get
their royalties to get more percentage
you know Microsoft's saying hey we don't
got a footing and everyone's fighting
for mobile this that's what I get out of
this mobile situation is real and those
who control it is is real I'm curious to
see where Google stay if if the rumors
are true that Google Now has shifted
their you know not being favorable
towards the Activision basically deal
going down for Microsoft because how
could that affect them long term with
Microsoft having literally the biggest
some of the biggest games in the space
Candy Crush
ugly mobile Diablo what is it Immortal
that's the name of it yeah on the mobile
joint you know that that's kind of
offense money and then they would have
they would I would assume if they have
their store that can pull things off
other stores
I'm very curious how that works if they
do it
the only reason that I'm skeptical on
that is because that's against the model
that they've done everywhere else
they've went where everyone else is and
I feel like they know people are on that
Android store people on that uh yeah you
know that Apple Store it's like the
steam if you're not on those two stores
the most powerful you're reaching
probably 10 of the audience you actually
could reach you know I feel you have
Microsoft's movements are an agreement
kind of alignment with what you're
saying the reason why it's curious to me
is because there is one company who is
that which is epic epic was like we
pulling fortnite off of get out of here
like epic was like you coming over here
they know how strong yeah it's
interesting but that's all I got on this
so we can move on guys a lot of super
chants
okay
now go ahead dude no I just have some
merch um a couple merch from last from
this week shout out some people got the
um oh they got the Cog they got the the
leg Gator with the with the Avenger
gaming ninja okay they going full ninja
with it somebody got the love whatever
you do with that if it's if it's a yes
you don't I'd endorse that yeah we do it
will be no one lesson
[Laughter]
it's a new
question you say King David inspired you
hey you were motivated yeah yeah we
don't want to do that though oh okay
yeah yeah yeah whatever you do you do
alone Jim
get your dirt on it while you're lonely
shout out to look there's somebody got
the face mask somebody got the crew oh
they got the white sweater the IOP white
sweater you know what I'm saying crew
neck for the winter time you know what
I'm saying so we go all right we all
caught up with a merch I can't wear
white like that for some reason I'm just
dirty yeah
remember for 13 months Lord bronze now
we ain't going nowhere all we did was
hear what happened he wasn't in any way
shape or form included in any
transactions super chats for donations
then we got Filipino beasts five dollars
trying to hold off on buying a console
to the mid-gen cycle but couldn't resist
the series sto just got in today wow all
right absolutely that's right it's easy
that's what I'm talking about B
little man with another one no maybe
outside another convert Apollo Cooper
five dollar Super Chat little man out
here and only tighty whities and a Pele
Pele putting his Dukes Up Get Out The
Way Big Bertha PS5 oh very descriptive
[Music]
descriptive move it on then we got Tom
Tom from Toonami five dollar Super Chat
inflation is gonna help little man flow
off the shelf this holiday yes it is
people really got a little man back on
this one hell yeah we'll be in the store
right now with squabbles
we got topaz girl 175 Super Chat Costco
has Series S for 239 for the console
only 279 with the console and stereo
Xbox headset whoa a lot of bundles out
there yep who want to know what BJ's got
Paul there we go voice election remember
for 36 months Lord bronze Series S will
rule this holiday like it has been on
[Laughter]
we got blade X5 Super Chat thank you sir
appreciate that that was holding all of
this context behind that me okay lead
there was a bend the knee back being him
made that he he as he's doing a man of
his word you know okay
that's all for the games better days for
the game man but salute to you what was
the knee Bender I forgot we had it was
what it was probably either the PC stuff
anyhow you know see it's funny how he
know it was abandoned knee but he's not
giving his content
your money I respect that because
there's other dudes Lamarcus stars that
um has not been in the chat oh it's his
bet Lawson you know he's he's in that
chat he's just shaking yeah I know he
changed his day because I know what they
do I know what they do see they come in
here I know how they move you know what
I'm saying but see the thing is we show
our face men of our word bit of
Integrity you know what I'm saying
that's what we do and that's why blade X
is a man of integrity salute to that man
yeah
wow
oh it's a legend remember for two years
two dollars a series that's called
dominate Black Friday okay thank you I
appreciate you okay then we have Tai
casares 15 Super Chat the two that got
snubbed in these game awards a seafood
for game of the year yeah let's talk
about these Awards and Jen Taylor for
her performance as Cortana the weapon
and Catherine Halsey have a great day
Lords yeah that's right she did triple
Duty there yes
that's how you do it yeah exactly you
got triple bags that's it we call it all
right cool first of all let's salute the
legend Dairy ACG in the bank what's up
brother doing so I don't know if I'm as
legendary as you guys bring in Hugh
Hefner back
I was watching you guys from the start
and I'm like what in the hell exactly is
going on right now I was channeling my
inner Ric Flair but he was awesome
my favorite wrestlers of all time man
the only guy who could slap you hard
enough to possibly kill you
we're still is he's still wrestling out
there at 75. oh he's out of control he's
a beast no thanks for having me it's
gonna be uh an interesting one I had an
interesting conversation about this
already yeah I saw you making a round
shout out to the Game Boy daily Cruise
yeah shout out to them gas man eclipse
the most just absolutely I forgot what
it's like being on a specific podcast
for like a console yes and he took the
one section
and I was I was and I had people dming
me instantly and they're like like dude
are you gonna you know like you're gonna
ask him to extend that section I'm like
nope
so basically there's more context to it
oh dude there's so much he does I love
him though you know I love games out
there like he's like trying to focus
when I saw that and I was like
but look man before we get into
basically what we do is our traditional
yearly crowd in the Lord segment we go
through the major categories without the
Esports guys just the Gabe stuff mostly
and then we make our prediction right
solve is the reigning defending multiple
title winner so what we do is we out of
time yeah
yeah you gotta stress that brother
you've won this so basically what we do
is we make our predictions on the
categories that's that's there and then
when it's a game of the year we give two
extra points right uh attic that's how
we do it okay cool before we start the
Traditions we're gonna include you ACG
or this and we can come back and we can
revisit how everybody scored after it
was done I wanted to talk about your
comments other than that because I've
seen you said some really really
passionate statements about how you feel
about the game awards you know the
categories how things are structured so
I wanted you to get your thoughts off
overall about the announcement of the
awards how you feel about it uh the end
so my problems with the awards or the
announcement of what we saw well my
problems with the awards are that I
don't think Gamers should have to
um explain away anything you know you
see Jeff uh who by the way I even said
in the thing I have no issues with Jeff
I have no issues even with their
reasoning for it but if my seatbelt
doesn't work in a car I'm not the one
sewing it I'm not the one fixing it I
can call up the car manufacturer I'm
like something's wrong what what happens
with them with the split months and the
weird months and recency biases and all
that stuff I do have an issue with and
you hear a lot of podcasts big
journalist in because almost everybody
has a podcast right and even they say
that they have to be reminded when a
game release the prior year to fit in
the game yes and I find that if they're
saying it and they're so I'm not I'm not
voting if the voting people are saying
it then they
then there is a real issue and I would
like to see that repaired and when Jeff
says hey it's because of ads
that has nothing to do with me
um is what I'm saying I don't I'm saying
you should represent the year as a year
goes for the normal casual person which
is January 1st and just and and you
worry about the ads sorry no and and
that's not I I feel that companies are
starting to put a lot of
weird and companies as a whole I put in
a lot of weird pressure on Gamers to
make exceptions like I'm not quite sure
in this day and age you really want to
put a gamer on the spot because there's
a lot of choice out there too and it
doesn't take much before you know
somebody starts watching YouTube Awards
instead and we've seen it you guys do it
um I've changed mine I don't really do
game of the year I do like a focus One
impact of the year because game of the
year is filtered pretty that's pretty
yeah
um but people start watching those more
and if you start you know alienating
things and start making it weird and
that that does bother me and the reason
why I was so passionate yesterday and
not so much today is I have not gone to
sleep
I'm reviewing games and I gotta tell you
I forgot when a bad game
can destroy your soul oh yeah oh man and
I am like oh look at dude I'm it's one
of those times where I stayed up because
I was like dude if I go to sleep I won't
play this yeah I gotta get it done yep I
gotta get it done yeah so if I'm a
little quieter it's not because not
because of anything nah you're good I do
I do appreciate it but that's my issue
with Awards as a whole and I I'm glad
you said it because you know I'm at the
point me personally I'm just exasperated
with certain things I've I've learned
not to get as the last two years I think
I was really pissed off at it and then
it started yeah and I'm just like okay I
know what this is now and again I'm
trying to be respectful I'm not saying I
don't know how to run a show you know at
the end of the day I know there's a lot
of pressures involved with it I I do
agree with some of the recency bias and
I do agree with a lot of
miscategorization of certain categories
of what a genre a game is why something
is in there and you made a good point
yesterday too like
my thing is I just want Clarity on
explanation on how you came to this
conclusion right exactly like there's no
explanation right it's just kind of like
be quiet we it's a very defensive
fighter yes like thank you it would be
great to have when I started the channel
I was telling guys I did a mission
statement when I was reaching out to
YouTubers uh and I was like what do you
guys do how do you make your rules and
they were like what's a mission
statement I was like oh no yeah because
I have to review games and I have to
sort of give every game a chance so I
have to have one I would love to see the
game awards be like this is a fighter
and this is a brawler and if it's a
brawler it's going to be here and that's
the seafood thing which I see a lot of
people and I don't even know I haven't
got my brain wrapped around that yet
because I really want to look at what
they have but there is some confusion
there right yes and uh it's one of the
reasons why I would love to see game of
the war a year go away is because
somebody brought something up very
intelligent in something I think we've
all thought and maybe not said which is
that the fact of the matter is eraser
most likely won't win but a racer to me
Forza for instance might be my game of
the year because people want to play and
they're driving their drivatars and the
technology is amazing and all of this
stuff but it's like Game of the Year
probably it's going to be rare So if we
did impact of the Year where you could
say Elden ring for example impact
developers are talking about it gamers
are talking about like versus Game of
the Year game of the year is so noisy
filtered if you're trying to look at
filters and you look at game of the year
it can be really rough and I think that
that would be a awesome Clarity to have
no I beat him maybe go away from that
those are fantastic points man yeah it's
so much to discuss we could go Audrey
I'm glad you got here you're good at it
I was gonna say I feel like when
OverWatch won game of the year that year
impacts video would have made more sense
because when OverWatch came out it like
revolutionized that whole thing and that
would have made more sense yeah there's
a lot to this man and again
you know it's interesting this year
because I'm seeing pushback also from
journalists and not just you know saying
and the reason it's the first year lit
up yes some agreed but most actually or
some disagreed most were agreeing I mean
like I can't say this or I don't really
feel comfortable but it's like you're
you're a lesser I'm just a YouTuber so
they're like you say it yeah
this is the first year I've really seen
a lot of pushback like there would be
some pushback every year but this year
it's just can I ask you guys why you
think that is do you think it's because
we're all doing podcast one thing I
think is that a podcast doesn't let you
control
um your your it does it you talk and I
think that the more journalists who do
podcasts the more there isn't a very
opinion perfect uh article it's them
talking and then and then suddenly start
thinking things I don't know yeah
I just honestly believe that before the
money the big bigger money was
introduced it was it was a little bit
more pure right and you saw us in the
pure State and we was all happy for it I
remember oh you know we got an award
show we was happy to be there and then
when we got there everybody started
looking around like what is here and now
you're starting to really look under the
you know we noticed that the emperor has
no clothes looking and you're like oh
he's dancing to his own music here all
right what is this showing up here this
is not my gaming this would make more
sense and then once you have a
conversation with all these podcasts and
then you start to see that there's a
commonality in it like yeah we believe
that this game should be there and
everybody's questioning a certain game
that's there then you start to look for
is it nefarious thoughts in it or is
this ads here or is this this company
then you just start looking for things
it could be pure could not be pure but
again the more money that's there the
more chances for all this nefarious
stuff to happen I don't particularly
agree with game of the year and award
show stuff right I really don't because
I feel somebody let's say the way I feel
about Somerville I can honestly hate it
right right but then there's somebody
that can get it and they can have a
life-changing experience for them and
they don't really get a chance to play
something else and that could be their
game of the year so if it wasn't called
game of the year does that person feel
lesser than type of thing I just I don't
know I just I think the titles of it
need to change like Carrick was saying I
think if we say impact of the Year
people will be more apt to say to yeah
you know that did have a good impact you
know and and it doesn't pigeonhole it to
this was the most uh important game
because I brought secular based off a
game of the year and it sucked like hell
of me because I can't play it
I forget it I think what irritates me
the most isn't the nomination isn't how
the process I think the process needs to
be reamped it's just how they treat the
actual people getting the rewards like
mostly like you'll spend half the show
talking about ads or you know clearly we
we like the the previews but still
that's not what the actual show is about
but you'll do the majority of the awards
off stage yeah but you only really keep
it to like and you're not that it gets
Esports I know a lot of people like
Esports but they let a lot of the
Esports stuff happen on stage and it's
just like I feel like that might be more
towards like the monetary value maybe
Esports and them have a close
relationship and you know it's kind of
like I scratch your back you scratch my
back kind of thing and it's just like it
when they Rush what's uh the dude that
one game of the year Joseph off last
four years they rushed him off because
obviously look let's be real here he'd
be real action sometimes you know maybe
that's the Lively guy right it's just
like he just won his first game of the
year thing yeah and you spent two
minutes talking about McDonald's ad or
doordash ads but you're not giving him
60 seconds to make another level
infinite commercials no it's just
AKA who tense
and I'm not I'm not gonna act like the
money portion isn't important it's about
the money portion there's not gonna be
another game of the year next year but I
do feel like you can put the the awards
should be 50 50 with the money you know
because I think there's a way to do them
both it's just they they seem to be like
okay you know let's just push it all one
way you know let's get this dude off
let's let's do these three Awards back
to back off stage yeah like you'll come
off of like a commercial or a uh it'll
be like yo these games won you should be
like what that's that's not good yeah I
agree I agree like you gotta respect the
devs to me on that yeah I guess to know
the way the gaming Awards is done
because I feel like it disrespects the
industry yeah
I mean I'm glad it exists we didn't have
anything right I come from
you know gaming is one of the best
mediums and now to me surpass movies
like it is it's a beautiful genre so I'm
happy we got uh you know Oscars I even
didn't even mind when they used to do a
little people thought it was quality
where they do the little orchestra music
for all the weddings I actually like
that I like it I like the thing I don't
like is when they have like a live band
there like no one cares about it but if
they're playing like but you'll play
your persona 5.
that's fine I'm talking about when they
have a band there Oh you mean like when
they had a badge attraction or something
something yeah like Green Day take that
group you take that green day off you
can give all the developers like yeah
you want the music for the game you
don't want them yeah okay that is a
gaming event I want to see gaming
related stuff I don't mind the
orchestrates because that makes sense
you know the game of the year is a big
award for them so it makes sense to go
through all of their soundtracks and
then yeah yeah eventually give it and
you know another thing I could say I get
it celebrities
you are true you are right when you say
Stars matter or whatever but
um I'm not 100 sure why you don't now
when we know Terry Cruz or Henry Cavill
who like games why they aren't the ones
doing it I like the rock but he doesn't
know about games but I got to talk one
time years ago to Sylvester Stallone
didn't know about games but he did a
Rambo for Sega Master System yeah he's
like yeah if you're in trouble I love
that game love that game let's grab
Henry Cavill and show him for one minute
I can guarantee you more people are fans
of Henry Cavill because of games and
nerds and Warhammer than they are sorry
is acting yeah and even if you see the
people who truly uh what's your name
I think she's doing peripheral right now
but she's a huge gamer yeah bring at
least bring people on that you know
tangibly and the homie they brought up
on last year the homie that did um the
star said uh he's a gamer yeah yeah he's
a gamer yeah I definitely agree with you
guys keep them kind of people there like
take the rock out take uh me uh what
What's the other chick that did it with
him yeah she can go too
another thing that I wish they would do
is like you know let like the voice of
Leon Kennedy get get get presented award
like let the people voicing these actors
present Awards like and especially if it
makes sense if you're doing like right
now I have it up as most anticipated
game final fantasy 16 uh the the Harry
Potter Resident Evil 4 Starfield The
Legend of Zelda there should be one
voice actor from one of those games
presenting that award like you could do
that eventually occasionally like or you
could say last year's winner is
presenting this year yes
yeah treat it like yeah the best way
there is doing that it's like it only
makes sense yes I think the reason that
they only do that they do that
I do remember they do that with game of
the year right so most likely Joseph I
think is going to deliver it because
they did they did it with Naughty Dog
the year uh last year okay if I remember
correctly but I think the reason they
won't do that is because of all the
categories it would be hard to keep off
all those people it's like we got to
make sure they're here at this amount of
time yeah you got options but look
somebody get your balls over this get
into our Crown the Lord I want to see
what you just thought overall about the
you know the controversy around it or
just are you feeling okay about
everything about the game it was this
year someone just said something good
but why has Snoop Dogg never presented
an award like he's an Xbox gamer he was
detected he was attacked he was at a he
had a stage it's right you got you got
Van Diesel in the Rock presenting
rewards but I mean Vantage was different
he actually he actually owns a studio
yeah he actually is in the game thing
but like
Snoop Dogg the dude who's literally on
Twitter all the time complaining about
games because he plays them so much it's
never presented an award yeah maybe he
didn't pay
moving on I know where you going you go
that corruption because I ain't touching
it but I know where you're going I know
it's kind of kind of kind of point there
like if you notice a lot of the
celebrities that is presenting Awards
they have something that they're low-key
promoting the year after the rock is
promoting Black Adam
Black Adam sets up the next award for
game of the week they was doing movie
promotions too yeah
it's the double-edged sword that this is
the world we live in that's it like
either we we get this and we get gaming
kind of pushed to the Forefront and have
to deal with the stuff that we as a
hardcore Gamers aren't fans of or we
don't get any of these eyes on it right
stuffy again it's the cat's 22 but you
got to deal with it I'm not happy about
like when I go when I look at game of
the year and I don't see games that
belong there and I see the cat game
there because people love cats and I'm
not saying that game was a bad game not
at all
I don't consider it a game of the year
quality I don't see it as a
transformative experience I don't see I
don't see people's reasoning that that
there was like the Zeitgeist moment
where people were putting up you know
videos of their cats yeah their cats
reacting or their pets reacting to the
cat on screen you know we had we had our
man on from the international [ __ ] his
cat was reacting this cat was reacting
shots
that you know a great game does not mean
Johnny Johnny
it objectively I think just does not
belong good Game it objectively does not
belong amongst the best of the best of
the Year again when you when you want to
categorize it that I agree with
character it's like man sometimes it's
very hard to put stuff under that
umbrella
for four yeah let's go I'm done moving
on yeah I mean again and then a lot of
what I find that bothersome a little bit
about games media is that it feels like
there's this conflation of Polish
with greatness
um and not every you know you you heard
the term polished turd I'm not saying
any of these games are terms I'm not
saying any of these games are turds I'm
saying that exists for a reason right
they are games again you you look at I
look at Horizon forbidden West that is
the most beautiful gorgeous open world
it's more of what made the first game
great and it's almost too much of it
it's so it's it's so polished and then
when you play it for me personally it's
me personally that game is just a whole
bunch of a lot it's just a lot of Polish
and not really
doing anything more beyond that right
for yourself be careful it's fine for
them
I know how this devotionality of games
hey I feel you but you're selling it
ain't up there what did King call it
what a king call it he's like baby baby
Assassin's Creed like it's yeah
Assassin's Creed light light there you
go so it's just it's that thing but
again it is so polished right well not
not when it launched this before not
when it launched if you look at God of
War God of War fantastic game fantastic
game
people like to conflate polish with the
great greatness and it's not necessarily
still we're not over the Red Dead red
ocean thing sir
it just seems to come from a place of of
you know something else
has a point because like when you look
at a lot of these categories it's like
the same four games and it's like are
you really having Awards or is these
four games the rewards like and it's
frustrating when you're looking through
these categories and you see the same
four games where it's so much when you
see one that's not God of War Horizon
zero Dawn stray or Eldon ring you're
like yo that's cool like yeah part of me
wants to vote for them just because it's
not those other because it's not those
other four games they also adds
something just really quick yes it
builds on what you guys are talking
about with Polish I do want to remind
people that Elden ring had a patch that
made it worse than reviewers right
that's right I remember that I remember
and I purposely dipped my my cuss word
um uh Horizon zero Dawn had a huge
number of technical issues with one of
its uh modes I can't remember it was
quality or performance a number of
shimmering issues all kind of stuff
recency bias it is a thing it does
become a thing polish becomes a thing
but the biggest problem I have is what
actually attic just mentioned
at some point we have to stop having the
same four games in the same categories
yeah so I'm not saying you should say
you can't be in multiple categories but
there has to be some way where a a game
that's oh I get it in the movie stuff
but well I don't even get it there but I
would love to see them say Hey listen
man you know this game's in two
categories the max now from now from now
on we're gonna make journalists stretch
a little bit yeah we're gonna let them
stretch and and you know your hammies
are tight man gotta work on your back
and these guys uh they only they don't
have to stretch too far because I'm
gonna be honest I would say a lot of
them I'm just saying so I know you're
gonna say it some of them probably go
well I'll give this one game and I'll
give this one this yeah there is less of
a thought process and I would love to
see them go okay
have I played this game right um Cult of
the Lamb it's like have I done that some
people haven't they haven't been a
chance also Dying Light I'm not saying
it should win Award right um but you can
buy all the games at the very same time
in your cart you can't play them all and
what happened in the first part of this
month was three massive games yes and
what I would like to see is uh is is a
stretching of the requirements to get
into multiple categories to where you
could say okay man you can't be in five
categories we just can't yeah
to gaming I agree I mean yeah I mean
again I I when I look at that game of
the year category and I see stray I'm
like everybody has the right to love
what they love right but and and like to
attic's point the fact that there is
that smaller game that's in there I
appreciate that and shout out to them
but when I think about games that
represent gaming as a whole there's when
I talk about the people's love of like
polish and and and again the kind of the
Sony formula third person over the
shoulder action game type thing that's
what's considered to be the best of the
best regardless of Polish that's what
they look at when you look at games like
again like I said vampire survivors is
an insane it is the essence of gaming
that game play that game again vampire
survivors oh yeah dude that is the
essence of gameplay right and another
game that got shafted in this regard
tunic
to me was you look at it and you like oh
the cute little fox Zelda game when you
play that game that game ain't that yeah
it it it really subverts the
expectations you have for what you see
when you look at that game and then when
you go turn nothing when you look at
straight it is essentially the Sony
formula the third person action game but
it's a cat right
um it just feels like that is what
people gravitate to irrespective of
content of the game and and the what
what it brings to the the table in terms
of the essence of gaming I'm not saying
like again Horizon has great gameplay
I'm not a fan of the world whatever or
but I God of War has great gameplay when
you look it and my beef this year is
straight okay I see
you straight to cut all the strings it's
straight it is it is a cat simulator so
and I and I remember people talking
about the game being like hey you know
it's just it feels like but how how much
impact can it really have if only five
percent of the people completed it oh
there you go that stuff happened this is
the thing and this is the thing right
it's a carrick's point it's like hey
what are these reviewers how are they
sort of processing this like hey I
played this I played this a little bit
but I liked it better than this I'll put
it here I wanted to get it Shine so I'll
vote for it here not here right yeah and
it just I honestly think it's a
different issue too before I know we're
going along with this but I do agree
with somebody which I said I do think is
because you look at I look at ACG right
and you guys to be the the creme de La
Creme of reviewing right and and in my
opinion the ingestion of all the games
you guys are viewed per year right so
you have this very wide palette of
experiencing the most of what the year
have offered and my concern is and I
know we brought up the forza stuff
before the past my concern is are the
reviewers able to play the vast majority
of these games because if you have then
I think you have a more balanced Outlook
and then we don't get all this
consolidation of the same games in
multiple categories you know I'm saying
that's my issue because I feel like
there's so many games and I'm like wow
they weren't even mentioned like they
were they didn't even get a nominees
I think it's I don't I don't know all
the reviews but I do think there's a
good amount of them that probably didn't
even play all those games and all I want
in today's season point is just the
clarification on how you got the
decision for for the for the games like
what is the process right you know right
as opposed to it you know very defensive
you know what kind of thing response
when you ask kind of thing to me when
you see Foo and fighter of the Year ouch
I just see that it's like you don't
understand
well it's not that they're the only way
I could think of that even being
possible if someone wanted see-through
to be there there's no reason for that
game to be in that category unless
someone wanted that game to be in there
or you didn't play enough fighting games
to to you know bro let's be right
you a gamer you know what a fighting
game is like there's no way you don't
there's just ACG do you think that
people honestly feel like if you would
put the majority of gamers in front of
seafood you let them see that do you
think the majority of them are going to
say that that's a fighting game like I
had to head fighting like that's a third
person brawler that's my point like but
maybe they don't have a camera and I
will give it I will give it this I will
give it this Seafood has more fighting
games
the joke goes it's the Dark Souls uh
yeah exactly yeah exactly absolutely it
is definitely that but it's not a
fighting game so maybe instead of having
all of these categories that no one
cares about start putting categories to
split these games up like a like a
brawler what about is what the fan said
y'all just mad ain't no Xbox games
that doesn't make any sense also I
didn't like pentiment I know you is one
of the things that popped up for me was
people like oh it's just Xbox and I'm
like you're talking to somebody who said
Mario was better than any of the games
oh Mario Rabbids it makes no sense it's
because people take a snippet and they
want to prove it
all that don't defend yourself okay easy
there are Xbox games on there
they're just not exclusive Xbox games
but if anybody tries to say it's it's
like because it's Xbox that literally
makes no sense it does if it's not
exclusive game of the year that would be
the PlayStation Awards right yeah
that's quite literally the dumbest thing
I've ever heard
we're happy about games of the year and
I'm not even as big of an issue with
stray being I mean because I didn't get
a chance to really experience that yeah
but as somebody who played a ton of odd
games Mario got on there a little bit um
circus electric uh didn't get on there
which would be good as a strategy title
there's a lot of games I played where I
look and I'm just like we um you know
the fact is is you go to your you go to
your family reunion if you're just
banging your cousins you're gonna get
the same house
it's kind of hard to put any of those
other games when they have four games in
every category oh you realize would you
guys like to see a six game what are
what are their Max for games in a
category do we even know that I don't
even know that yeah
I think that it might be easier yeah
I think one of the a way to balance it
look I don't know anything about this
this might mess up this is just my
perspective it's like every game gets
like a token kind of and it's like you
can vote for this game three times in
the entire nominations
and you can't vote more than three
because then you're gonna get more games
because people will be like oh okay God
War obviously Gotta Go game of the year
right obvious has got to go direction of
the year and then maybe action adventure
or whatever of the year then that's done
God of War is currently not in any more
nominations and then you'll get the
other big games the game of the year
where they feel like they have the most
chance to win so they'll take that with
like audio design and you know artwork
money down they send the money down all
the categories and the last one I said
we gotta do the awards
a cut off because I feel like for when
the submissions are it's just
inconsistent January 1st December
December
[Music]
now here's my question to you guys
recency bias is a huge thing it's going
to be like it's going to be hard for
someone
to to like put themselves they just play
God of War great game and then they go
they they're they're playing God of War
a week ago now they're voting for God
award would be Game of the Year first
off most people are still in the
honeymoon phase they're not like coming
back playing a couple other games how
many times have we played a game in
January or in the uh January and then
like well you know I would say like
August we're like yo there's a lot of
issues in that game right there was no
one talking about the amount of trolls
that was in God of War 18. until like
six seven months afterwards so I'll tell
you what I talked about God of War
Ragnarok having a slow ass middle
section though yeah the one that puts
you to sleep yeah bro it was rough for
reviewing that game because if you don't
want a certain thing you're stuck with
it and you're just like yeah
[Music]
that's why I feel like recency bias is a
thing and maybe you should like you
shouldn't be able to even put a see then
that's a gray area because it's like yes
if you have the day end of the eighth
and then you can vote on the ninth for
for nominations you're probably gonna
think of the last hot game you play
because it's on your mind yep so we can
also tell you something that happens at
it because I did talk to people about
this once we talked on the um podcast
there are also people who go back and
play older games and either notice more
issues because it was a year ago prior
to Tech being fixed or what happened or
it's been polished up and they're
playing a game that's been polished
because they're trying to re-remind
themselves if they want that game to win
and that did pop up a great deal this
year because I did talk to a couple
people who were reviewing like they went
back and they were like oh you know this
feels cumbersome now or this feels
better now I mean it's like well you're
not really you need to unpatch your game
like I mean there's things that do
happen do you think that real quick so
do you think that's like a trade-off
where it's like games that come out
towards the end of the year they get
that recency advice but games to come at
the beginning year they might get that
you know second second wave of people
playing the pre-patch six months later
so I think you actually yes no no he was
asking Kerry
um real quick uh yes it happens but it
also happens the opposite where people
uh the recency bias and you can hear
this on podcasts because again
journalists do podcast I've had Gene
Park on mine you guys have had multiple
people on yours um shout out to you guys
for always getting good guess but when
you have um those guys on they will
admit over time that the recency bias
also means that they refresh themselves
on older games and they get a difference
there okay and so the recency bias is a
thing that I'm not as worried about as
the dates right okay I'm not at all in
fact I would say I'm less worried about
that I'm more worried about lodging some
rules here's a brawler here's a fighter
here's a couple things for this and
here's your dates and then all of us
could go okay right now I know the exact
day and and you can just sort of move
from there and that Clarity would so so
with Carrick do you take notes when you
when you review a game to sort of remind
yourself like how you felt about it in
the Moment Like do you just so you can
go back and be like hey this January
game sucked when I played it and this is
why I felt this way no but I do take my
um because I don't script reviews so I
take my I take my notes that I make for
something funny like something's really
weird and I'm like what the hell is that
right or if it's really bad like right
now and I take those
um and then I download to find out what
it is I download my MP3 of the YouTube
I'm just afraid that it's a game that
I'm I'm very nervous bro because yo
leave Mom we go
[Laughter]
ain't nobody's nobody's remembering that
next November isn't Halo supposed to be
in this should be exactly it missed last
year but why it ain't in Game of the
Year
Halo infinite yeah
maybe we might need a mid a mid-season
refresh it's just like cholesterol
protocols if that's a good game
cholesterol protocol every six months
next year all right so let's go pull up
the screen
so are we starting with just easy yeah
we're skipping Esports game
athletes that's how soft wins yes
the game I understand the athletes the
team yeah he right Esports best Esports
game we should we should vote on okay
shout out to my Jets
we don't watch Esports
put it up for the people
there we go all right there we go all
right so we got
Counter-Strike Global Offensive golden
two League of Legends rocket league and
valorant who put their chest out first
what's going on I'll go first
ACG definitely League of Legends just
because everybody I've talked to um who
does Esports like they like the other
ones but and and Rocket League's
certainly up there but League of Legends
dude that's all I hear about from people
that I respect that they like get normal
games I don't mean normalizing those are
abnormal I'm saying valorent who are you
valerical Valerie King where are we
leaning I'm gonna go League of Legends
because because
of Johnny oh yeah oh yeah
that's who I'm talking about yeah our
League of Legends see and that's the
part right there I'm listening to the
people that actually play it yeah I'm
gonna go with Johnny I'm go with
Johnny's pick please
defending champion
I'm gonna go valorant
ballerin Valerian hasn't gotten his sign
yet so I think it's time you know how it
goes yeah it might happen for you
now I'm gonna go in the league I'm gonna
go a league
this is where you guys mess up
all right continue continue moving on we
got most anticipated Game of the Year
Final Fantasy 16.
president I did I mean we got to read
what it mean though cause they gotta
understand
okay recognize I'll read it then you
read the category so recognize the
announce game that has demonstration how
do you pronounce that damage
demonstration
potential to push the gaming medium
forward the most anticipated game to
push the media forward who's going first
we got Final Fantasy 16 Hogwarts Legacy
Resident Evil 4 Starfield The Legend of
Zelda tears of kingdom
you know what happens when you go with
your heart I'm not good
just jumping out the wind look it could
be Hogwarts I know a lot of a lot of
hype this is a hard one this is a hard
one Zelda we know Zelda you know what
I'm saying as far as the anticipation
you know what I'm saying there's no
doubt and that could easily win I'm
gonna go with something though I I think
there's a lot of pressure on it it is
literally the most anticipated gamer you
said yeah the anticipation was up it is
it is but if you if you read it
I'm going by the letter Lord I said push
the medium forward
no one reading this they don't care
about those texts they look at this most
anticipated game what am I most
anticipated that's all they're doing
because okay so what you got
I I want to say resident before uh who
going there I want to save Resident Evil
4 and it's not because I'm going with my
heart because a hype around that game is
crazy every time they drop anything on
that game it's just it is intense but I
gotta say something
okay
come home it gets me to turn my switch
on
gotta be Zelda okay all right so those
other straw
ACG Zelda yeah I would say star field
but push the dude Zelda's got so many
kudos for pushing gaming and open world
forward that it's pretty hard to be it's
it's pretty hard to be I'm going to
stand on my screen yeah Zelda okay cool
oh this is all right adaptation
recognizing this is a hard one to
recognize an outstanding creative work
that faithfully and authentically adapts
a video game to another entertainment
media
I want to say this is an example of
recency bias versus something uh that
happened months ago because I feel like
Sonic the Hedgehog would have a huge
standing to fight this category but it
came out so long ago I personally feel
like cyberpunk Edge run just gonna win
yeah with I mean man for same Edge
Runners
did Arcane come out this year it came
out this year yeah it came out I believe
and because you didn't know it came out
you should probably pick something else
no that's fine
yeah it felt like it came out last year
um
Arcane hands down
um okay I've seen every last one of them
the best one for me is cuphead
yeah I love no I'm not picking something
that Uncharted PlayStation Productions
no but see and I'm gonna say this the
Uncharted I saw set pieces from the
video game in the movie
yeah that was good right for those
people that played the game Sonic is
really good really is not the best
adaptation but I gotta go with the
recency buyers with with
um the cyberpunk
um so I'm going with the cyberpunk yeah
watch we all get this wrong cyberpunk to
me hands down Edge running I was out
there I was out there no expectations
for that I saw that out there for the
premier shout out to CD project ready to
have me out there that day was
phenomenal yeah you could make an
argument it was better than the game at
the time
is yes I want to introduce something new
okay since we only did one let's just do
this one what would you pick on your
heart because I want to see you with
your heart if you would have won like
yeah I'm going with Sonic that's what I
would have went with my heart
would have been Sonic yeah I'm emotion
based anyway so Texas says Arcane came
out November 6 2021. okay good go you
see I told you
I told you remember he said we're going
to be right back into that I don't know
we're gonna get into that so wait Islam
are you doing the vote you Italian now
are we doing it no I always go back and
take it I always go back in town no
doubt okay
debut Indy for the best debut game
creator that's an awesome category by
the way I just want to point out yes I
do love that this exists but a new
independent Studio choices are Dion
white Norco sure
tunic and vampire Survivor I'm saying
vampire survivors
who's jumping out the window first I'm
saying vampire
I'm jumping straight out the window
because the one straight wins yep that's
what I feel is this way straight
straight out with vampires all right
there you go with your heart no doubt
this is tough
no this is the strongest category by the
way yes it's Norco is probably my heart
but vampire survivors dude I can't get
people to shut up it's ridiculous so I
mean you guys heard about like uh Phil
Spencer some people play that game and
they were like the only way I got
through this level was because it feels
better it's like everybody's playing it
it's ridiculous
it comes through here this day is
beloved
I think so
go ahead
part of me thinks straight on one game
of the year I don't know why but part of
me
I'm a little vampire survivors
King and soft thinking
my heart is vampire survivors even over
tunic my my head the champion
what's your
heart called
my heart yeah what would you want to win
what I would that would vampire
survivors to win okay because part of me
wants to do these tallies and it's like
if you would have went with your heart
would you yeah
would they have won I don't know [ __ ] it
could have what is you know we trying to
win this is Crown your lord well that
that's why I feel like we should tally
both of them that way we could see like
there's a lot of talent because because
wait why you wait since you're telling
the heart might as well tally both like
you're gonna divide the word yeah look a
kid you gotta vote
um my heart will be tunic
um vampires survivors is really good but
straight I think it's the only thing
straight is gonna win so and uh and
being that I'm a new PlayStation Plus
um what's your tag on Playstation oh my
my tag is this is for everyone who um
wants to follow me
you want to be a part of the king Nation
[Laughter]
it don't even show it up just how stupid
it is
uh Xbox lover Game Pass oh thank you
thank you
thank you for your new ID so I'm going
with straight All Right Moving On Let's
Go
oh this is a this is a tough one are we
doing it yeah let's do it why would we
do this we never do these though let's
not do it
yeah I'm not doing it all right best
multi-player for outstanding online
multiplayer gameplay and design
including Co-op and massively
multiplayer experiences
irrespective of gaming genre or
platforming folder know what I mean
these are Call of Duty Modern Warfare
tool
multiverses OverWatch too so but two
three
a turtle shredders Revenge very
competitive I'm gonna jump out the
window and say OverWatch too
[Music]
even with all the little controversies
you got Nintendo wow he is platoon
Multiverse is very very highly acclaimed
people was rocking and rolling
Call of Duty one of the strongest
entries
oh this is tough stop what you're doing
I got a fake ball I gotta think more I
mean
it's tough I don't know the Multiverse
has really had its moment and then it's
been quiet but quiet doesn't mean quiet
quiet doesn't mean it's not killing it
yeah
um
platoon 3 went Bonkers
I covered that joy in that packs West
State that he was in there going crazy
for whatever reason I feel like people
play Shredder's revenge so a lot a lot
of people play this solo and then we
played are we eliminating Ninja Turtles
off rip I don't see no one vote for
Ninja Turtles yeah it just kind of feels
like I mean no no I mean people might
have the reasons but I just feel like
it's one of those things like you play
it and it's one and done like really
like you know like
I don't know man oh man
ACG quiet where you at
tough I mean I hear so much good and bad
about Modern Warfare I can't figure out
like if it's good or bad because my
discord's back and forth on it and I've
only played a little bit OverWatch 2 I
hear a lot about even though it was
really negative prior yeah
probably man probably OverWatch will win
just go and buy you know okay so you're
an attic on OverWatch
I want to make a mistake
this is where I can mess up right here
damn let me think it I just don't feel
Splatoon even because it's isolated to
the switch yeah yeah I just talked about
that breath of the wild Power
Nintendo energy dominating this is
different than experience
not to be rude I'm not trying to deball
that discussion I'm just saying we are
playing Splatoon versus the hope of
Zelda
um Splatoon big you said it's big in
Japan like it's it's sold more than any
like uh in the shortest span of time it
sold like three million copies or
whatever huge really yeah like it's done
really well I don't know how that's
translated over here right
yeah I don't think I don't think it did
in the same way you're hot in your town
you local
oh man I'm all right I'm going earn 10
in your school
so what are we doing what are we doing
I'm doing OverWatch oh is coming down to
me I'm eliminating uh Ninja Turtles it's
great it's Co-op even though they
including co-op in the category
I'm kind of leaning with y'alls for two
and three not being there just it's
great to me Multiverse had a legit shot
yeah
if it had dominated the conversation the
rest of the way yeah yeah right now to
me it does come down to Modern Warfare 2
and OverWatch to me and Modern Warfare
gotten really a lot of clean like it's
the first Buzz people really kind of
like modern warfare back see the cars
they excited too Bobby
um damn but OverWatch 2 is OverWatch
oh this is tough I'm gonna make a
mistake um
I'm gonna go Call of Duty has never won
I will say one thing called what's up
it's it's it's the ones that people
choose when the other ones choose one
that ends up making them win sometimes
yeah then you try to trick me out yeah
you also don't lose any ground we all
lose so y'all mostly went with over
oh I'm gonna go I'm gonna go with my
home I'm gonna go with Modern War I
think one year model will fit gotta win
in the world they've never won it they
stepped it up that's for sure that's
what I'm hearing this is the people are
hitting me up all the time about it all
right I'm going I'm gonna go with it
hopefully versus OverWatch too question
what's the one that you think's gonna
win it probably OverWatch okay I'm doing
them live right now yeah I'm going yeah
I'm going my heart but I think we'll
watch probably will win it most likely
and what what was yours King
oh I didn't say it oh okay okay so I'm
going with uh Call of Duty oh definitely
because of the recency bias and the fact
that out of all of them is the one that
really pushes the needle Ninja Turtle
doesn't push the needle Splatoon pushes
the needle around its block OverWatch
two made the transition over to free to
play so that could have a big uh Gone
genre uh shifting thing but yeah not
really and multiverses is just a
watered-down uh Smash Brothers so
um I'm gonna go with Call of Duty
refining and doing what they do best and
oh um Splatoon is what my heart would
pick yeah I'm switching to Cod I'm
switching
there was too much negativity OverWatch
and I don't again it could be hot
continue to be hot behind the scenes but
there's no talk about it right now and
the recency bias thing is real so I'm
going with Cod number one so what what
uh solve what's your uh want that you
want to win it but I would want to win
it I want Turtles to win it to be honest
but I'm picking I'm picking Cod and King
what's yours that you would want to win
it oh Splatoon
and called you your actual pick is Call
of Duty but yeah you think you think uh
oh uh Call of Duty is going to win I
think yeah but I'm going my heart on
this one
cool we all good moving on yeah all
right let's go
hit the button
hit the button
best sports racing for the best
traditional and non-traditional Sport
and racing game formula 122
FIFA 23 NBA 2K 23. Gran Turismo 7 and
olly olly world oh boy what do we got
who's throwing their face out first I've
thrown out like multiple times it's
someone else's team I think it's yeah
FIFA the last FIFA under EA yeah I think
it's FIFA okay what what do you what's
what's your want my why would be Ali Ali
world my one would be all y'all I want
would be all the world I don't think
what you got ACG what you got same Ali
Ali world for want and FIFA for sure for
for the winner
I'm mimicking ACG
and this is where I lose oh um I'm going
with NBA too you're going with 2K
I know this is this is where
this is not this is where my ignorance
as an American shines through I feel
that you know the World sport somebody
hit me up with the yo King who are you
gonna watch the World Cup
and my ignorance to it I don't have a
team so therefore I'm not invested in it
right so here I'm looking at all these
categories and you know what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna go with FIFA because I'm
trying to win I feel that I would say
NBA 2K because
um it's really big in in the states
basketball is really big Lord Metro just
pointed out that Lord Metroid said the
World Cup started today oh yeah yeah
well I mean and just like that's
flooding in yeah yeah that's that's hard
no one has Gran Turismo no
transactions
yo everybody's voting uh I want I'm
gonna say FIFA but I'm gonna say I want
two cat I only play 2K I don't care
about none of these games but I know
plenty of people that love that game so
I'm gonna say 2K for you guys okay but
my pick is gonna be FIFA 23. yeah
over now
and what was your walk call my what was
Ollie Ali Ali were
and I think that's a really good game
yeah yeah the next one
best Sim strategy best game focused on
real time or turn-based Mario simulation
turn Mario addict Mario Hart and oh he
already did I think Warhammer will
probably win because imagine has
exploded yeah he gave irrespective or
platform Doom spice Mario virus you
heard ACG total Warhammer three two
point campus very good Victoria three
what are we doing yeah Mario got to win
Mario's got to win like this
the fact that I see attic raving about
it after how you felt about the first
one and I actually DM to me on that too
yeah I love the first one I like the
first one he was very mad about the
first one the first wasn't perfect but I
still liked it but he was very but to
hear you Rave about that the Stars I was
like nah I got to give it up
so want and heart
want and all right okay for me Mary
Roberts
all right who else is that everyone
already what no no Mario rabbits for me
as
the the that's what's gonna win I think
uh but yeah Total War Games you just
brought about Total War I just don't
know what I think more people played
Mario rabbits as opposed to Total War I
think Mario Rabbids because of the fact
that it it's it's more easily appealing
to more people I think just more people
played it
yeah so Mario Rabbids for the win at
Mario Rabbids for Hope yeah
okay so both is Mario for you my mine is
uh Mario rabbits for the win and
two-point campus uh two-point yeah
nobody's a Victoria three family I'm
like dude those games are impenetrable
by the way yeah like might as well grab
your rule books and your old tones
but man when you get in there oh so good
all right everyone's everyone's
accounted for yeah yes family game for
the best game for family play
irrespective of Gyro platform yeah we we
all tripped on this one last year oh
this is Nintendo's category we tripped
up last year on this curvy Lego Star
Wars burial rap this is tough Nintendo
switch Sports and Splatoon 3 that's
family
Hmm
this is tough you know what's funny
yesterday uh during the attic show I was
like what's worse
um not being nominated at all at all or
having four games up here and you still
lose this is the category that's going
to separate the winners right here I'm
saying Lego right
they're gonna let go okay I'm going Lego
that's what my uh not multi-air not
exclusive either so I'll go with Lego I
just think more people played that
and I'm gonna say Mario for the best
family that I would want yeah
I'm gonna go Lego and I'm gonna go
Nintendo Sports uh for the uh my want
I'm gonna go Lego because it does have
more platforms but I actually want
Splatoon to win something
um you know what I'm saying like I feel
like platoon should win something about
it's just it's a tough category it
wanted to block yeah bouncing around the
neighborhood so if you voted everybody
voted uh no not yet um yeah Splatoon for
the win oh I think this is why they win
because again switch Sports didn't do
switchboard all right Wii Sports was a
phenomenon but mostly because it came
with the machine right I mean yeah Mario
rabbits again I think it's it's
impenetrable as a family game per se
Lego Star Wars true yeah and then Lego
Star Wars that newer generation kids
aren't big on necessarily A Star Wars
Lego yes I don't know about Star Wars
and then Kirby again Kirby yes but you
can't you can't really go back and forth
with it I think I think I thought I'm
gonna go with Splatoon family shooting
up in Splatoon busting pink guns yeah
but it's paint guns that's fun I I think
I think a Splatoon from
for both well you know what no no you
know what platoon for the win oh my
heart Kirby because I want to see Kirby
die
hold up hold up you should Splatoon for
the win in your heart curvy okay I
already switched it I already okay
moving on okay we're good
sorry I might have to do this like alive
best fighting games the most
controversial category but the best game
designed primarily around head-to-head
combat primarily
dnf duel
are
King of Fighters multiverses
controversial Contender
losses happening this is where things
get spooky look this category is so easy
I'm jumping out the window I'm gonna go
multiverses for supposed to win this
this is the category I feel they're the
strongest
um
I'm gonna be mad I love see if I would
be mad at Seafood even
because he's here and how great he is
that he could pull this off that the
fact that he's included he got me what
you want
you want I want Multiverse I'm going
Multiverse is one and I'm going the
whole thing whatever like I think about
the first we need to get something I'm
just where I'm at with it I thought it
did a lot
I agree multi versus both both I agree
I'm offended to see who's here and I
love you sifu but you're not this is not
the club you're supposed to well I'm
gonna go with the fact that the red
herring is in the room
I'm gonna go with the fact that they
somebody want to get somebody
everybody
they saw the trailer they played the
game is like this game gotta get
something so the fact that a broiler is
in with the fighters
you're 100 right yo kick yourself right
King could make a great business
decision I'm going I'm going with
seafood
and then my want being that I'm such a
Neo chill oh
Fighters okay
I'm uh no not yet ah
I want to say Multiverse you know what
I oh I'm gonna do it oh you're making a
business Seafood as what's winning and I
want Multiverse to win
yeah
Multiverse both yeah okay everybody's
accounted for all right that's gonna be
a fun category to watch what happens
oh basketball player game for the best
game design with Rich player Captain
character customization progression
included massively multiplayer
experiences Elden King live I live live
and live live if that wins I'd be upset
Pokemon Legends
triangle strategy oh that's a good game
that it was a good game Xenoblade
Chronicles the streets are talking this
is intense best role playing with Elden
ring is in here chilling
what are we doing
okay I'm jumping out the window if Elder
bring down one game of the year
they come through
the only RPG that I played this year
that I lost my brain on let's go that I
was streaming on Twitter okay come on
so if you pick this does that mean it
doesn't win game of the year then then
this whole stuff is a fraud
if you got the greatest RPG that's up
there if you don't win you sir this is
fraudible
ring is my my it gotta win
my heart would be triangle strategy but
if Eldon ring wasn't hit then it's
triangle strategy can triangle strategy
as great as it is upset I didn't hell no
yo it's just it's impossible like the
the game is Just
it's just the best
just that some people pick that game up
and talk about it's the best RPG of all
time so no but what about what about
y'all you know the the parameters of
what RPG is you got Zito Blade
Chronicles three in here y'all nice
strong she cute she cute
[Laughter]
she cute amongst her family
somebody got a bend the knee um
it just did again live alive coming back
is fantastic that people played that but
again it's it's on the switch and again
it's just when you I look at it and
people start comparing it to like oh but
it's not you know xano blade or whatever
like same with time with strategy those
are great games but I just see I just
see the Press kind of looking at them
like oh but it's not as much of AAA
experience as you know a Xenoblade or an
elder ring so I think Elden ring just
did some amazing stuff this year it's
addict
that's it
I'm gonna say let's go where are you at
I'm gonna say no blade just winning
I want Elden ring to win
yeah because I feel like
a lot of this is politics no matter what
they say
uh and I feel like they're gonna give it
to xenoblades because Zeno's not winning
games of the year
so this is the Zito blade you know
consolidation what is it what's the word
again constellation consolation I mean I
don't know man yeah I don't know I don't
think this might be where I where I mess
up okay
it's an amazing experience that I really
enjoyed
but when you got two Heavy Hitters like
Elder ring and Xenoblade I just don't
see a world worth triangle wins I'm
going
with a business decision
Elder ring gotta win something
by mentality my logic is if Ragnarok
wins Yep this is where Elder Ray comes
to clean up
I'm calling Elder ring for the business
decision win
for my heart I'm going for triangle
strategy I would love triangle I would
love to be wrong and see like an Essence
pure kind of not no just my brother
right you know what I'm saying other
ring is out there but I would love to
see a classical piano style I agree so
that's where I'm at but I think Elden
ring this is my get out of jail free
card game of the war if I lose
[Laughter]
ACG
where you at
um so I don't love jrpgs but Xenoblade
Chronicles is incredible yes it is so my
heart would be Xenoblade okay okay
um what you're doing I think that it's
there's about 18 levels to the pr and
trying to guess what they're gonna
choose versus what I wanted to choose so
I wouldn't say oh CF Elden that that is
the thing I don't necessarily think
people are going to think God of War is
Ragnarok is better than Eldon ring I
mean I know a lot of fans who love
Ragnarok but there's like that uh
there's some this and that where people
are just fanatical about Elder ring yes
um so if I say Eldon ring will win this
then that yeah
I mean I actually feel bad for the other
three yeah this is like Xenoblade
Chronicles got me back into jrpgs which
I just did not think would happen to me
man that game is amazing so yeah
eldering business but uh who didn't vote
everybody all right let's go moving on
that's gonna be a great way to see yeah
I think when we see who wins that we
gonna learn a lot how this show go go
yeah and I I will say that because now
we know now I will say I will say this I
I I'm gonna do something special for the
Video Game Awards this year uh I'm the
one that streams it yeah all right here
we go bass action adventure for the best
action adventure game combining combat
with traversal and puzzle solving Here
Comes plague tale Requiem first
appearance God of War Ragnarok shows its
dominant face Horizon forbidden West in
the mix
the very controversial but baby properly
categorized
tray and tunic Heavy Hitters some
controversy whoa this is a tough one
this is a tough one what we doing fellas
jumping out the window first I'll go
first tunic heart
God of War is gonna win
um I would love to see plague tail win
but I know that tunic just I know a lot
of people love that and I I'll back them
up and say that I can tell Tunica
special plague Tales incredible yes but
God of War um it's puzzle solving Is Not
Great gotta wore ragnarok's puzzles is
probably the lowest of its uh they're
really generic I mean they're really
rough but the game is a whole I I
certainly see action adventure before we
ask any other person does horizon get
this can it pull it up no
I had to get his head up Rising
forbidden West says business decisions
so this is Horizon gets on the
scoreboard okay hear me out let's go
when Zelda came out and this this game
got like destroyed or nothing no Rewards
I don't feel like that's happening this
time I feel like they're gonna give this
game something Horizon I feel like this
is the business so like the best thing
we could lose
I think I think you're over yeah like
throwing a dead body out there he locked
it he locked it
award he's locked in don't don't leave
it don't talk about it don't talk about
it that's true all right and the one
that I want is tune it my heart I want
playtail to win this so bad but
this got a warrant here boy it I just
can't see no scenario
wake Out of Water walk away
I can't it's action like the genre name
doesn't it like this is one of the few
it's the opposite of the seafood yeah
like this is the this was Taylor Made
the way it is
the archetype of action adventure
God of our hands down well we can say
whatever we want about this game awards
and I do feel like they have a lot of
going but some of these some of these
these nominations are tacked like most
the time there's a clear winner but I
feel like there was a couple really good
games where it could go either way
absolutely okay this way you come in
with tunic right for the business
so just like you said I mean you got
straight in you know it's this you can
see a clear agenda yeah you can see a
clear gender people want what the people
want you know oh and some people want
what they pay for they
I think the cash was spread out
uh plague tail looks fantastic here and
everybody's been talking about playtail
is better game than God of War not today
buddy
comes the best action adventure out of
all of this who gives you the best
action you can't say Horizon gives you
better action than God of War you can't
say tunic or stray gives you better
action or plague Tales so there's a lot
of Adventure in um Horizon I got it and
there's a lot of Adventure in God of War
God of War eats this category up like
eats it up this is this is what this is
supposed to be they supposed to get this
right so in a natural world God of War
each this category okay but my heart is
Tunic so much fun in tune it perfect and
I didn't get a chance to play the other
three to be honest with you there's so
much stuff that I've been playing but
the two games that I did play I'm a vote
for so God of War and tunic who has not
voted me
itself same God of War for the win tunic
for the heart oh you betrayed Plateau
dirty trade oh no listen
you know I love Plato I have yet to play
this flake tail yeah okay
moving on attic let's go that was a
tough one
oh another basketball game here we go
here we go here we go thank you okay bro
for the best game in the action genre
focused primarily on combat the choices
are Bayonetta three she put the voice
actress name in there too Call of Duty
Modern Warfare is in the action game
category okay neon white
C4
now
all day this is what I feel Seafood
exactly Seafood for the win Seafood for
the heart because you know what yes
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles is what
those games used to be Seafood
formula I'm with you I'm riding with you
soft I'm going down with the ship this
is where I love some seafood
yeah I'm going down with [ __ ] I'm going
down this is where I want them to win
which I got
yeah
I want ACG to go before me
I'm a phone a friend
not to be rude but if you look at
Seafood it fits this category yes versus
the other ones and sorry but like modern
warfare Bayonetta 3
um has some cool action but man it's not
even close to sifu like it's not even in
the same
category so I would say Seafood for both
it really does feel like this is where I
would love for them to win I mean they
deserve to win this is just like
Ragnarok where it fits the cat at least
to me Call of Duty doesn't necessarily
fit as much oh shots
focused primarily on combat well it's
more cut scenes and then combat but I
mean it's campaign's good like Daddy
Taco is bad he says
he said y'all BS
band of the three guys
interesting you know be crazy there's a
lot of there's probably a lot of older
people voting and they voted teenagers
and the Cod can't people say yo Cod
campaign Loop is different room to room
they say y'all sleeping on cars action
oh no it might be it might be but we
might be I feel like it's it's between
seafood and Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
because like here's the thing a lot of
people vote they grew up with that game
yeah and a lot of them probably didn't
even play Seafood King your decision sir
um I love
the timing of controversy no
and I love
you do that you are not gonna do this
and and I feel being in light of the new
developments and the information that
was shed upon such a game
people want revenge
oh what are we doing so they're gonna
give bayonettity props what and I'm
going with Bayonetta here
this is where I'm gonna put my steak in
the ground and now and
I'm gonna go with Ben I'm with you king
that's the reason I I'm picking abnormal
because I feel like sometimes I want to
go with what I think's gonna win but yo
what was a lot of talk was messy he said
half the people voting for The Game
Awards can't even beat the first level
yeah once one of the problems I think
with this is they do say play they don't
say beat and we know that a game might
have a great four hours start and then
terrible like we've seen that before I
can see people with sifu not feeling
like they're even competent to vote for
it even though they played it and I
don't see an issue I don't see an issue
with that I mean like I I can definitely
see his his point King what's your watch
I want this Teenage Mutant Turtles
fantastic it's great but I just feel
that controversy cells have been that is
selling it there's a platinum's coming
out on stage for the wind all right
[ __ ] say thanks for everybody that was
involved
I think Seafood for the business
decision and I think Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles for the uh for the one
okay okay good let's go all right best
VR AR here we go yeah these are my face
for the best experience playable virtual
augmented reality mad that there's not
another game here oh yes right I know it
yeah
you know I know but you know it was
telling you should be here did Among Us
just came out like three or four days
ago but dude it's reviews Sky High yeah
dude I saw somebody saying like that
took Among Us and like elevated it to
the next level I'm gonna say that wins
but after the fall show after the fall
so good after the fall if you're a VR
fan and you don't own that yes
[Music]
um
Among Us VR is does does change that
game even more so and it's probably
gonna win my heart is after the fall but
I think Among Us VR is so strong it kind
of has given me
that Wings back into VR kind of yeah
like an extra Second Life a shot in the
arm yeah I'm gonna go with the business
decision is among us but my heart I
really would love among the fall after
the fall of the win even though there's
no resolution Studios and no demio here
yeah I'm gonna be a demo guy the
PlayStation back like after the four
came out before what did they have to
fight before though like and I think
after the fall has had a weird release
it's been out before I agree that's why
I don't know ain't here but all right it
is what it is that's what I'm going what
y'all got
oh my god um Among Us and I won bone
Labs doing well I had a lot of tech
that's inside that's gonna push the
genre forward yeah uh and it's gonna
give a lot of thought open up the minds
to people but a proven game that was
really a fun game now in VR I think that
could be a killer app to bring people
over so um yeah I'm gonna go with that
video ain't solved did you vote Among Us
for the win okay because it's because
it's Among Us yeah and and the heart
though like Kane bone live because bone
Works boneworks was freaking Bonkers
besides besides Half-Life Alex that that
game showed me what you could do with VR
and Bone Labs just you know expounds
upon that so no most book two votes for
the win no no
worries when you guys agree yes very
exactly this is very strong VR here are
like those Among Us on VR is sort of
mind-blowing if you think about
popularity and popularity and after the
fall as well yeah dude they're all great
games how many of these come into psvr
they have no announcement of bone lab
Among Us I'm sure hopefully they do they
all do hopefully hopefully hopefully
that thing sells at least a 2 million
out the gate I'm telling you right now
for people red matter too is amazing
yeah
that's the thing Moss was originally a
good game and then book two is awesome
absolutely all right attic did you get
your video I voted
be quiet yes no he's still thinking
I'ma just go with the safe bet
the Mungus all right yeah after the fall
of your heart
part of me wants to say after the fall
because Among Us was already nominated
and I don't know if they would do the VR
thing but uh it's just like look man oh
I'll be I'll be damned if I lose this
because I choose on a genre you don't
love among us as a game like you love
that game what's yours uh ACG uh mine
was Among Us a win but I would like
after the fall of it no doubt okay
moving on
getting closer getting closer Innovation
and accessibility let's do it I don't
know why I have been copying and pasting
this so yeah I think
um
accessibility
software some hallway that is pushing
the medium forward by adding features
technology and content to help games be
played
with this by a wider audience I'm going
with it I'll go first let's go it does
falls for the win
yeah
the Quarry uh for My Heart wait wait we
do realize God of War Ragnarok is in
this I don't care about that right now
he didn't first of all there was no
innovation
adding features
no help games be played no making my ax
turn to ice is no that's nothing shoot
that stone over there kid yeah
I'm going with dust Falls like I said
you're not gonna go get me out of this
one you're gonna trick me out of the bag
okay and the Quarry I'm gonna respect
your gay story
who's jumping out the window
um Last of Us Part One for accessibility
dude they're incredible we've had blind
people beat that game and the more
accessibility he's gonna add Ragnarok
copied and not in a bad way but they are
just taking Sony's doing a great job and
so is Microsoft these guys are like
where Nintendo still doesn't even
realize like what's going on both of
these guys are like pushing
accessibility today yeah so I think Last
of Us wins I gotta say my heart's Quarry
though because Corey Dude it lets you
watch the the game in different versions
like everybody dying everybody like
there's all kinds of different ways you
can experience which none of the prior
games from those guys who have done cool
stuff in the past isn't doing Quarry was
phenomenally good compared to what I
thought it was going to be and I have
not experienced dust Falls at all I
missed it and I heard that it's really
good this hurts so bad so yeah after
that go what it does fall so bad is it
that yeah
quickly just give me like because what
it is is okay it's yeah it's pretty much
like same type of game plays the Corey
and I think it's five five yeah five
five chapters and it might not be five I
can't remember how many chapters but
pretty much like you can have a bunch of
people playing you could play with like
a stream and you have to agree you have
overrides let's say you're playing ACG
and you get to certain parts like uh
certain parts where you can override to
make something happen but then there's
key parts of the story where it's like
you have to agree you have to or you
have to use an override and you can use
a phone you can use a phone to play and
it's cloud streamable and it's oh man
yeah I think I'm with ACG here um I
think the Last of Us Part One Last of Us
gonna win it and then as dust Falls this
is my heart yeah last of us is gonna
witness but I I would love to be wrong I
just can't jump out the window I guess
I should I should point out that the
Quarry has seven player mode as well so
I don't know if people knew that but the
quarry's got a huge it's got its own
wolf wolf pack uh Edition which is like
seven people can play in all this what I
worry about with as just Falls is that
it's just not enough people played it
yeah because I gotta be honest I didn't
think it would be good and it
it hit you know what yeah
I'm jumping all the way out I'm going as
that's false now there we go that's my
jumping all the way out I love that game
I love that game I have to jump out the
window that's very cool yeah I love
interior night I love what they did with
the choices
one of the greatest videos
I'm going down with the ship and then
add extreme that game I asked him as a
favorite to stream it and him and his
girl did it and it was one of the most
entertaining nah I'm going with that
studs for I don't care very cool we're
down with the ship all right so because
there was a lot of changing there yeah
sorry sorry okay so the Last of Us Part
One is dust Falls King as dust Falls the
Corey addict I'm using I'm doing The
Last of Us Part One is does Falls
Cognito as dust Falls as dustful
eight player mode
all right okay let's move on got to get
it out my system if I'm a loser lose one
that I like oh
best community this year recognize it
game for outstanding Community Support
transparency and responsiveness
inclusive of social media activity and
games updates and patches Apex Legends
Destiny two five
eight fortnight
and no man's Sky it's tough no it ain't
no what do you think you want me to do
this next one you do it okay I'll start
off fortnite
cake let's go one night and uh and and
Destiny is my heart but I'ma tell you
right now there is no title up there
that has the most support about the by
the community and by oh man that's
beautiful they got this stuff together
for how you did it and how you got there
I respect everything that you do but
there's one dude up here that just
kidding time
[Music]
yo listen if you can get at it to sit
there and play fortnite me
me I don't know
yes that's right that yeah
dude no man's Sky Beyond any of them I
don't even think fortnite's in the
running either I don't either and I'm
talking just this year no and just this
game awards version but dude no man's
sky is mind-blowing like I mean and
they're probably the only ones who can
do it because of the procedural
generation I do admit that that they now
as as they've got it fixed it is a
different style of updates than fortnite
no and all those and I I've heard some
stuff about Destiny but not a ton yeah
but dude no man's Sky I just they
finally added the the Casual version
which is like you can now you have a
bigger inventory you can decide if you
just want to ignore the ship part
starting you can adjust tons of options
no man's sky for me both want and
business solve I'm very curious where
you're going
I might lean my directions your way
[Laughter]
where's your head at so this is the
reason I'm not talking about I'm trying
to get I'm trying to talk to myself
the other pick is just as important this
is important because I don't want to
lose I want a big shot make the right
decision
[Laughter]
okay because when solve goes I can
decide to go off the winner of last year
or try to beat the winner by picking
something he has extremely Sound Logic
who won last year you forgot no no you
just me me you mean me yeah Oh you mean
yeah who won the category last year does
anybody know that because it kind of
feels like they rotate them
very good point that is I may need to
know game
let's see what that [ __ ] let's pick
after soft
I'd like to have this information as
well
he's like let's actually make a real
date I think Final Fantasy one last year
I don't know why but Final Fantasy yeah
Final Fantasy one last year okay Final
Fantasy technically so maybe because
they have the wrong Reborn do they do
they back to back I don't think they're
winning this year no they went back to
back here anybody voting Legends they
rotate these games in the next concerts
like
I just feel like that and then no man's
Sky did win at some point something I
remember because Sean Murray was
drinking during the uh
finally celebrating something after yeah
four guys winning in 2020.
[Music]
let's see 2019 Cruise
Destiny 2 winning in 2019.
I think Destiny for another one so then
I dropped the witch Queen
so at some point maybe it wasn't this
that no man's Sky won so I will say no
man's Sky oh my sky might be dude no
man's sky
and heart I give it to No Man's sky as
well again what they've done to that
game like show them listen
they they this is the biggest comeback I
mean besides Final Fantasy Final Fantasy
yeah and Siege is one of them too you
know what's crazy he he's doing what
Mike what I want Microsoft to do yeah to
not talk till they have results and mess
around and then again it's gonna get
another boost when that uh
Whatchamacallit when that VR version
comes out yeah yeah because it's already
big it's already got full support on the
on the VR system so you can get a
console version to sell well yeah all
right sell a child all right we we got
the Winner's opinion is is that gonna
manipulate ours
is always going to be there capacity I
thought which Queen was is that is that
what you want is that the business
decision that is not the business
decision
um the problem with Destiny is great as
witch Queen because people forget which
Queen not only is a fantastic campaign
that for Destiny is an amazing campaign
period the problem is I don't like the
part where they said transparency or
responsiveness to computers yeah I felt
budgie this year it's not I had to be
honest they dropped the ball at that
it's no man's Sky it's no man's Sky
that's the business I think it they've
just they've added so much I can't know
I know a king has got for that has like
destroyed the year like they had an
amazing year so if fortnite pulls this
out I can see where King going and I
just don't see I don't think you know
what it is this is fortnite has an
amazing year every year every year like
it really does by the way Apex Legends
Legends I have to admit is also always
solid so like always track this in the
same way so when somebody said has Apex
Legends won I'm like they sort of win
every year because they're yeah they
they pulled it out day one that's good
gameplay guys yes like if somebody
hasn't for whatever reason played that
game it is
business no man's Sky that's where I'm
at
everybody's good when everybody is
saying
yeah still teetering Alex teetering he's
gonna go fortnite this is where mistakes
get made
Apex Legends
I want to pick but I oh God do it do it
no man's sky has just done too much for
me to realistically avoid that like Apex
Legends continues to support an ongoing
game but no man's Sky Has Done massive
updates and I feel like it would go that
and it's not really even an ongoing game
they just made it that way like it's not
built for that they just keep adding
yourself to it I'm gonna say no man's
sky for the business decision in Apex
Legends for what I want okay this is
gonna be weird we're gonna see what
happens here let's go separate people
moving on all right so the next one is
we passed five o'clock I know we're
going to him I knew this was gonna be
long I'm going quick
yes Marvel snap
but I think the other people got a shot
but I'm going Marvel snaps now with
those the microchip I know I know people
love it it's snap and last year again
Shin Won right and I would assume
against him is just as great this year
yeah I think this year they give it to
snap though yeah
anybody else after going off the tower
fantasy watch your guyses want Marvel
snap yeah
double bubble snap for me he said I'll
take a double school
what about you ACG same okay for sure
cool moving on
best Indie
did someone lose it because of this this
way you're gonna lose someone's gonna
lose yeah this is tough
it's gonna go to stray
that's the business decision stray a
heart
the heart the coat oh to the lair man
business is stray but Cult of the Lamb
is what I wish would win
and I love seafood and I love tunic and
yo neon white there was a lot about
let's talk about neon white earlier in
the year my friends loved it I never
yeah does Seafood sweet though maybe we
sleeping on the power of seafood no
no
no
um tunic tunic for the wind oh I think
this is where tunics inside the door
right until it comes in it's the only
one they got a shot I would have went
with Colt to the lamb but Cult of the
Lamb had uh game breaking bugs in the
beginning I think God of War is gonna
win
of the game breaking bugs a lot of
people put down close to the lamb
really yeah they built they never beat
it and they went back because it got
corrupted or whatever whatever happened
and they had it was funny as I told Saul
I was like I'm not covering code of the
Lambs yeah I tried it I tried multiple
times but it kept glitching multiple
times I do remember now I'm gonna go
with tunic and my heart is cold to the
lamb and I was gonna go back to Cult of
the land where I guess when they patched
it up to play because I thought it was a
really good game I thought the visuals
was incredible it's tough man
oh
I wanna I'm gonna I I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go with stray coat of the
Lambs like I do I feel like Corner lime
deserves this but I can't ignore that
performance issue it's like like you
could say whatever you want about the
Stray it ran decent for the most part
like I don't remember the PC version
yeah the PC version ran horribly my
heart is actually Seafood again yeah
yeah my head says I was like keep doing
it the head says the fact that stray got
all the way to the top yeah that's what
I'm saying the game of the year
nomination my business is straight this
is Western economics for voting
that's where I'm going straight's gonna
put Seafood for your heart Seafood for
my heart okay let's go to the next one
getting closer best ongoing now this is
what genshin won last year I think
fortnite
oh see I didn't know this was gonna be
yeah buddy so I lost the last one I lost
the last one fortnite popped up in the
because the best ongoing got to be
fortnite so it's about to lose
listen listen listen listen Linda
I'm about to take this app this is where
the king don't get anything I feel it
that's what we do I'm gonna ride with
what gets me playing all the time
and I'm going with Destiny I'm going
yeah no no oh no oh I'm standing on my
Square what you doing Destiny then I'm
going with fortnite get it but I'm going
with this I'm going with my heart
destiny 2 had the best campaign in
gaming yes I don't care what nobody said
people play witch Queen they I can't
talk to them until they're playing it um
it's tough though you know these these
koalas all these can win so Destiny 2
for the business
I'm going I'm going business
people have not played Witch Creek
campaign until they played it it's one
of the best campaigns of the year that's
how good that campaign but you just said
it people have not played it nobody but
but
the ongoing game still goes to my
favorites
a budgie that game but look I know I'm
probably gonna lose this all right this
is the harp speaking mostly I'm saying
Apec Legends
for the business and my heart to Destiny
tube okay
ACG has been quiet Fortnight for
business oh fortnite does it and uh Apex
legend for heart
as a as a person who dropped out of
Destiny I gotta tell you guys they're
onboarding for new players is the worst
ever and
um so I can't I guess I can't it's
impenetrable at times I saw somebody
playing it I'm like oh my God so I
that's the only reason respect I get
what you guys are saying I just and I
want to play but my want has not
exceeded what I've seen uh in like the
onboarding the onboarding is awful for
new players you don't know where that's
what they're supposed to fix with
lightfall but we'll see moving on
uh it's off I'm gonna go with genshin oh
dancing for the win
and
Destiny 2 gotta guess what I'll give it
to you yeah
he's got the one he's got the one that's
what I mean
I I heard I heard that campaign was
crazy
I've uninstalled this but I at some
point I'd like to go and play that
campaign
we haven't moved on yeah I mean oh man
away
[Music]
I messed up I didn't know I should have
saw this I messed up I messed up
citizens
dude which you mean citizen sleeper
right yeah
I don't know all these titles I'm
dyslexic
um
I've heard that game is awesome and I've
not got a chance to jump in I'm a
mistakes
Extinction forever for my heart really
it's it's yeah so now I want to play
that yeah so so I'm going with those two
I'm probably gonna lose this genre yeah
yeah again
um yeah citizen sleepers definitely for
both
yeah for both okay no citizen sleeper
and endling uh Extinction okay and then
an Extinction for my heart
citizen sleeper for the win
as does falls for the heart no doubt No
Doubt
I'm actually taking your guys's heart
votes as votes for the next games I play
if I haven't played them too
so like when you guys say that I'm all
uh citizen sleepers like uh I can I
didn't even know what endling was until
now so I just never got a chance to even
check it out that's pretty good no doubt
I'm gonna say citizen sleeper
now yeah you're going first next time
we know an attic do it moving on
best performance
[Music]
okay okay
uh best
I am oh this is rough it's rough
because part of me wants to say it's
going to be a God of War person two
nominees but I know a lot of people felt
like Charlotte did really well and as a
plague tale that's what I'm going
I know exactly who's gonna win yeah
go ahead I have my feelings on this all
right so I think actually I had to go
first I got to go first yeah yeah I
gotta go first I'm gonna say
I'm gonna go ahead and say plexto what's
your heart yeah and and The Business no
the uh the the business is like it's
gonna be God War oh so you go God well
which which God
um why Christopher we know what
Christopher okay
okay safe nice and safe I like that
we're solving King is rambling about so
business that the winner yes immortality
that's exactly where I was going really
y'all not play that game
did you not play that game it's it's
immortality
and my heart is probably Plato
oh that's tough yeah I'm going I'm going
the same it's Sovereign I'ma tell you
man immortality I'm going business gotta
War Ragnarok Christopher Judge comes out
and says boy a thousand times
ACG
um immortality they're also the ones
that did tell uh telling lies or
whatever yep so they're telling lies and
her story and her story and I do FMB
games this is the only one I haven't
done but FMB games are like my secret
little baby did you play her story did
you play her story dude I played
everyone but I mean I play like the
Montreal crap Studio
I so but Chris judge won last year so I
don't think this is back to back okay I
do think plague tale she did I I
personally believe like the human shield
getting beat up thing that occurs in in
plague tale is incredible
um but immortality is all I heard of and
I mean it I heard and Robert Schiff from
who was Odin should be in here I cannot
believe he's not yeah but I would say
business-wise plague Tale Heart would be
immortality just because I'll just go on
what you guys said because I have a
feeling okay everyone's voted everyone's
voted give me one second I'll go ahead
and do it
all right oh we're not best audio oh my
face
real quick ACG what was your uh your
best performance ones uh but it was
going to be playtail or what I uh think
will win and what I would like to win is
the FMB game um
immortality okay thank you what are we
doing here best audio uh by far I'll
just go first business Call of Duty it
is the best
um sample wise and everything it's
unbelievable for guns all that and I
loved all the other ones but uh heart
would be Eldon
and I should stick with that mm-hmm
and I should stick with that you know
you know what yeah yes God yes yes yes
God yes uh because it's not gonna get
game of the year I'm gonna go with God
of War and best audio design and
um what I would have liked to win at
best audio design is Gran Turismo
because the way they sample the sounds
of the cars and stuff like that nobody's
got Elder
so Gran Turismo yeah for my heart for
his heart for his heart and what a war
for the win oh god oh my God
[Music]
I honestly I kind of think
[Music]
what are we doing so
I'm with ACG I think it's Call of Duty
wow and then in my in my heart not
because I love it or anything like that
but in my heart
kind of feel like the hardcore choices
Gran Turismo whoa
so it's yeah I think Call of Duty will
win it because of recency bias and but
not not because it doesn't deserve it
but again the guns and stuff like that
that they've always been very good with
that but Gran Turismo if there's one
thing that game does well is yeah is
everything the sounds around the car no
yeah so that's it y'all talking that
technical stuff but cog's doing the
popular vote again
God of War Ragnarok comes out the music
the sound you gotta see it the tears oh
yeah it's gonna be a pageantry I love it
you're gonna hear the orchestra I'm
going for the pot I might get the W this
oh God of War y'all being smart talking
all this technical stuff
let's go what you want uh my what no
one's actually Call of Duty I do want
Call of Duty to Win It
but I'm going for the popular vote
uh I gotta agree with you guys God of
War like it's just there's just no
denying how that that audio Design's
good like I I kind of want Call of Duty
to win but God of War is just so
dominant man how many times could he say
boy it's variations
[Laughter]
the different ones for vocal because I
think they are separating yeah
they're separating vocal from Audio and
Sound that's why but you're you're
speaking so eloquently and technically
so and this is not what this is about
so hold up real quick solve Call of Duty
uh Gran Turismo King call uh God of War
Gran Turismo Paddock God of War Gran
Turismo Point Cognito God of War Call of
Duty
Call of Duty
best scoring music
[Music]
oh
God I think music inclusive score
original
song and or licensed soundtrack
when it comes to play Tale But I think
plague tale should have this thing is
pretty good
um
he's a red herring
no one's got Elder drink huh you know
what listen I don't care I probably lost
this anyway
um give me metal hell
you see him speaking what do these kids
do with their own thinking
stuck up the rakes
we haven't seen him all day here he is
he out there with the Red Sneakers I'm
going with him Jake I'm with you I I
just I mean I say that I haven't played
the games I'm frauding I'm going for
points again just it's interesting that
he got here who are you and your whole
premise what's your what's your guyses
want then my my what because I'm using
hell I'm metal singer too damn I didn't
place you know play dog I don't know
what's going on I feel my want is um
play still I'm gonna go with metal
helsinger as the win I'm going what in
heart bro I just want this I just love
that it's here let's love it I'm just
like yo I like that you're here so we're
gonna shout you out for everything
yeah I think I think mental health
singer for the win
and play tail for the heart okay okay
addict
uh I I said it um metal okay AC mine's
plague tail
put his foot down on the Square house
and Saul have you said a plateau for the
heart for the heart and metal helsinger
for the one it'll be nice
and used as a plateau ACG yeah she said
one end yeah okay getting close
press art Direction
one of these kids doing his own thing
now it's your time to put in for score
oh whoa
stray
oh Horizon
God of War
best art Direction outstanding creative
and Technical achievement in artistic
design and animation I got it
I I can go go yeah please okay well
Horizon forbidden West my man I was
thinking to see the best art Direction
out of all of them
yeah God of War because it looks better
than God of War but can it bunk out of
what okay yeah it could it could
um because I don't think it's gonna be
in any place else that's how I'm looking
at it I'm like this is the only legit
award Horizon got a shot maybe yeah does
it but I've oh this is tough your
thought process is simple to mind so
mine is rising for the win and I would
want
scorn
I would want scorn because I wanted to
play that game in VR that's how much I
love it oh God
okay I'm going all right Horizon look
like the best looking joint to me
I don't think it's gonna win but I'm I'm
going for I'm going business on it and
hard on it I'm going for Horizon I want
them to pull that game look beautiful
it really dude it is open I know God of
War probably gonna smack everything here
but I'm I'm I'm dying on this [ __ ] I
will harassing y'all to bug him
[Applause]
I think I'm gonna lose with this one
what you lose it with
I'm gonna say scoring
yeah
the only thing score got going for is
the weird art just uh Direction yeah
the fact that it's here you got a good
point it sneaked through the back door
oh a sauce shaking his head at us oh
did y'all see the craziness that is an
Elden ring did y'all really see the
craziness that is an elder ring yeah
it's Elder ring that will win art but
let's be real here bro
the way the game is built what is
different from Dark Souls from
bloodborne I mean bloodborne
software as you can see all of the
bosses being any other game
okay okay but compared to this right
score all right scoring is just gross to
be for the sake of being gross that
doesn't necessarily mean good right
direction you know if it was funny
there's always one don't get wrong yeah
yeah I just think Eldon rang the further
you go into that game the more crazy
stuff that you see and it's just like it
to me the amount of work and effort that
went into creating the that wild world
if you look at Ragnarok Ragnarok is
beautiful it's more of the same of the
first one I'm talking okay
listen I I think that's it and I think
and I'll be honest I think the heart
would be straight because I just think
straight might might stop the cat
instead of stop the cats okay what's
yours what's yours um because they're
combined uh and Technical achievement uh
Elder ring definitely had issues and so
did Horizon but I would say Horizon
um for business like if I'm looking at
everything together
I like all these and I think straight
could win but I my heart would still be
actually Horizon dude it's neon and
dinosaurs which is like I mean inject
that into my life yeah
the best African-American representation
in all Horizon just want to say for the
record
I'm just say we look good in there we
look good
outside that's narrative let's go
outstanding
storytelling so
narrative development in game solve
uh-huh plague tale Elden rig boy Horizon
this is gonna be spicy
the business decision
is Ragnarok because I just feel like
it's ending that duology
the biggest decision is Ragnarok
the heart
and I think it's a mortality and your
immortality is here you go ahead you cap
it hard
yeah I think I I don't know if something
tells me once we start getting to these
categories up here I just think that the
thinking Narrows the final three barrels
this is what breaks us who's jumping out
next
um
and immortality for the heart okay
and I would say God of War
um yeah and plate tale of her heart but
God
jump out the window
it's about midday
um
I'm gonna say God of War uh god of war
and a plague style because I I feel I
feel like that that that's a good thing
look he wants to be last
has to go to God of War because oh
hip-hop hold it no no yeah
you know what it is you know what it is
Carl's about to speak god of war and
he's trying to get as many people not to
take God Elden ring changed the game I'm
going with uh god of war and um because
the narrative was being talked about
constantly and no at nauseam and I'm
gonna go with uh plague still from my
heart
I supposed to stay on your Square anyway
stand on your Square
god of war with the most narrative the
most talking from section to section the
most narrative or inflection of or
anything what's your want we get it oh
we got it all right moving on final two
come on let's go last two electrical my
dentist best game Direction
oh awarded for outstanding Creative
Vision and innovation in game Direction
and design I am going with elder ring
Eldon ring all day I got my votes yeah
I'm with you ACG Elder Ronaldo ring
based on that award
yeah me too yeah
Alden ring across the board attic
business oh God that is the same thing
same thing
there's just no way if you're not
jumping out you're not you're not
convincing me not to jump out like I
it's it's Eldon ring they're like this
is the one that I can honestly see like
just sweeping this whole thing yeah I
don't I don't see it not winning and now
for the championship the bonus two
points if you get this right you get the
extra point this is what we are here for
let's just say it right down straight
right everybody cross the board let's go
Game of the Year recognizing the game
that delivers the absolute best
experience across all creative and
Technical fields
it's straight come on everybody right
the hands down oh I can tell you mine
holding ring
this
is
two points mine's out and ring mine's
Alden ring it's all been ring with the
heart being played tail that would be
funny
yeah I would love plague tale to win so
my heart goes for like popular vote
let's just just take this whole thing no
I generally want this game oh should I
go for the pop Jack Keely did say he
felt God of Wars Sonic Frontiers
look at you
it's supposed to be
it's supposed to be yeah but sit with
your heart says
come on mess it up two points is two
points though yeah man two points is two
points you can win this whole thing I
could literally
I could lose it myself because really
like
like you have to win two others that
that person didn't get haha yeah because
this this is we could this is the
catch-up mechanic
or the one that puts you behind the
eight ball well it's got to be healthy
man it's got to know what happens
we know you're watching I want to take
god of water upset people
okay so you once got a war and I just
want to see the world bird
I wouldn't see the Dark Souls at the
screen there's a part of me that wants
to see the Ragnarok guys laugh at the at
the elderly God there's a part of me it
would be funny Twitter would explode but
I don't read needs to win this other rig
needs to win this all right I just need
clarification on one thing
um it is best man I did a bunch of the
best multiplayer you said Cog you said
your like your business decisions Call
of Duty and your uh want is
um is OverWatch right yeah
okay just to make sure you got
everything and we're done I need one
more with uh ACG same thing your your
business decision is OverWatch and what
was your want
oh Jesus dude that was a long time ago I
know I'll tell you them real quick it's
it's the only one I did because it's the
very first one yeah the the choices was
Call of Duty Multiverse OverWatch
Splatoon 3 and Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles and you're asking me what my
heart is yeah what your heart was
uh
over Overwatch no Call of Duty
the meat is funny he said no the world
would burn a straight one game yeah
[Applause]
so we got it here crowd your lord tuned
in where's the game it was a date what's
the date we don't know anything it's the
eighth I think yeah the eighth but what
I will do real quick just so we know
that I got the right ones is imma just
share this document real quick and just
go straight up and down like just so
it's on record what I've what I put down
all right cool cool
or King's stomach is rumbling yeah
King's dying
okay
I'm gonna be wearing Shades all week
two games
my batters my bladder is about to be
yeah
just just go just go just go you're not
get the Super Chat sir
hold on a second I mean oh I'll do the
poll I did I'll go yeah go ahead we
didn't get many during this but I just
got one in right all right uh with Phil
spector's latest interview stating the
importance of overall gaming business
which of these do you think is the most
important to Xbox's long-term success in
gaming a powerful console Hardware
presence B PC game pass growth continued
to increase C developing Xbox mobile
storefront presence or D I don't care
all that sound nice but y'all better
have some AAA bangs that is the vote
right that is going up you know shout
out to ACG for coming through yeah that
was a blast this is
ggs I almost got to be tradition like to
get that extra yeah it'll be fun to see
yes if you ain't bad if if you ain't
busy you need to come back yeah I
actually like he needs to be a regular
part of this this is so much fun yeah
and uh so I'm gonna get the Super Chat
yeah quick we got J1 two dollar Super
Chat thanks for entertaining me wait a
minute I'm too many oh too many not
bathroom run worthy ready
or just change the name of the uh the
name of the game to 80 of the year of
the year so yeah instead of games that
are only uh 80 of the year Randy G5
Super Chat we a category best movie game
okay then we got flame remember for two
years two dollars I feel like Sav is a
dog person I smell corruption yes I am a
dog person I'm allergic to cats I love I
love kittens if they stayed small I I I
I'd like cats more then we got c-wbu two
dollars Super Chat I want straight to
win just for the salt
there you guys Bart goes 172 problems
with Jack Keeley finessing the industry
boy gotta hustle it
85 for the chat this is why I don't take
game awards serious in music and film we
have academies uh in gaming you have one
Dorito Pope dude controlling everything
twenty dollars I preferred Horizon zero
Dawn than God of War I mean
those puzzles are fillers like when
people put flour and omelets
just pulling up on emptiness that's
crazy
We Trust
then we got Bruno Ramos deals again five
dollars we chat I played Halo on the
Xbox One X and God wore Ragnarok on the
PS5 Halo is better sorry take it from
the Xbox dude that went PlayStation 5
first on this gen okay okay then we got
Bruno Ramos DS again ten dollars Super
Chat I would vote Uncharted as the best
adaptation the movie is as BS as the
first Uncharted game wow that's crazy
and we got rrd remember for one year two
dollars which had ACG you were great on
game on daily yes oh thank you yeah
fantastic then we got rocks something
that kid [ __ ] Roblox I guess I had
copy paste and I can't really tell what
it is here Rock something five dollars
yo yo I'm finally catching a show live
thanks for the chat yesterday King also
vampire survivors game of the year No
Doubt salute much love to you all for
the best podcast thank you thank you
brother much much appreciated then we
got Stephen bet with the one pound Super
Chat thank you sorry that we got Bruno
Ramos Diaz again five dollar Super Chat
it's accident Adventure not puzzle
Adventures the horizon or tunic of over
God of War over God of War
heads Bruno Ramos deals again ten dollar
Super Chat game of the game of the year
Elden ring for the heart business God of
War Ragnarok oh okay people still think
that got a war got a shot last minute
y'all caught up yep as many times as Cog
says are are you sure we need to make a
shirt that says are you sure
your time time yeah all right Ty okay
yeah Lord Lord attic I mean first of all
Lord ACG yeah absolute pleasure that's
just all thank him at the same time so
we don't have to do it thank you thank
you
Jesus
let's all do it like where can I find
people find you what you have going on
Sir uh anger Centaur gaming you will see
reviews for a couple games coming up in
the next couple days most of the NDA so
I'm not going to say that and because
I've talked a little bit about here so
um yeah there'll be some reviews and
another AI fake review for uh I think
we're gonna do I like those dude they're
a blast to do uh I think we're gonna do
no man's Sky oh okay that should be fun
to do what you think you know that
everybody said the outro is the ECG is
addict's gonna get upset if we don't
yeah we're good all right
off the stage you can find me saying it
next week
no it's not we're going to Five People
You can find me killed over a urinal
somewhere yeah
rocket scientists with the Canadian
that's a scientist I was like huh yeah
that's why I was so like we're like we
have topics like usually this takes like
an hour and a half just by itself yeah
two dollar Super Chat you know shout out
to you yeah Lord King gonna find people
find you in the Versace robes oh yeah
fantastic you find me Tuesday at uh 5
p.m with attic as we uh continue RNR
with the Lords fantastic stuff that
we're doing and I want to appreciate
everyone who showed up and I'm going to
appreciate you for showing up again next
week great Tuesday see you then
appreciate everybody appreciate
everybody for pulling up again it was a
lot of fun please uh everybody with the
Joshua interview and everybody else
anything sorry about to say something
yeah wrong good scientists LOL it's
rocket science it is I got it right I
got it right these guys figured it out
for me everybody enjoy your Sunday ton
of fun we will see y'all next week peace
he's fine